well pursuant to the executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically this is a public
this is a public meeting in which we are
executing various bills which we have
previously heard in the education
committee please note that there is no
physical location for members of the
public to observe enlisted
contemporaneously
to this meeting however in accordance
with the emergency order I am confirming
that all members of the committee and
select legislators staff have the
ability to indicate and temporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform in the
public past access to contemporaneously
listen and if necessary participate in
the meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendars and through the
electronic calendar on the jonesport
website the notice where this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing to
call
271-3600 email HDs at ledge.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled I want to
interview staff that's supporting us
today we have Jennifer for our committee
researcher please note that all votes
that are taken during this meeting shall
be done by roll call vote let's start
the meeting by taking a roll call in
attendance when each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know law thank you very much
morning everyone
good morning good morning
representative here in the committee
room representative Aller here in the
committee room representative here in
the committee room
from San marcett here in the committee
room
representative here
representative Andrus
here at home alone in Salisbury
from Senate Ford
they're in my office in Chester alone
represent way on here in the committee
room
representative here in the committee
representative uh home in Kentucky by
myself
here
Shaw here in the community room
representative Cornell home alone in
Manchester
representative Tanner
hi uh here in Sunapee New Hampshire with
my rescue dog Raven representative
Allison uh I'm home alone here in
Concord
representative Mullen here in the
basement in Bedford
representative lay I am here I am home
alone in Jaffrey New Hampshire
grandson
here in Santa Claus New Hampshire my
wife is present and my dog will be
barking at some point
and representative Ladd I'm here in the
committee room
of me thank you very much uh for an
announcement we have been accepting
bills and I I want to thank the
committee for getting these committee
reports minority and majority reports in
although there's a few hanging out there
um and uh I I'll go through the ones
which we don't have seeing that our
administrative assistant is really
looking for that right now
um on in regard to HB 500 School food
waste uh I'm still looking for these
that was a 22-0 votes on the calendar
consent calendar I'm still looking for a
representative license yes I know thank
you uh on HP 140 that's the private
rights of action uh that was a 12-8
ought to pass uh I have the majority
report but I do not have the Minority
Report
um
okay and
um going down uh on HB 319 that has to
do with post-secondary Civics testing
uh I do have uh the majority report but
I don't have the Minority Report yet
from our UTS so
um we'll get that to you okay thank you
very much
69 HP 69 that's displaying the national
motto in schools I I we have a split
vote there that most of us not fast it
came out 10 10.
so there's no recommendation uh I do
have the report from represent Tanner
but I don't have a report from reps and
Hobson for the uh that side
so everything else is in and I really
appreciate your getting that to me today
we have some bills that are coming up
and also we have several bills coming up
in the Senate which are right up over
there
um and the first bill I believe that was
the 110 bill which was uh adequacy
distribution that was uh Representative
Steve Smith's bill I think he's over
there testifying so nobody's passage yet
but we will be in and out throughout the
day and I'm sure others will be in and
out by the remote access
so with that uh are there any questions
from the thing I don't see any answer
any questions on that so with that I'd
like to go ahead and start accepting our
bills today the first bill up here uh HB
-561
.
that's uh a bill which deals with burden
of proof and special ed hearings
so it's
open right now
for a motion from representative
cardelli uh thank you Mr chairman
um
could we make sure the microphone's
operating because it was
apologize thank you thank you
on House Bill 581 and offer Amendment
zero eight two three h
and is there a second
representative Owen I have the second on
that okay you do yes perhaps so we have
a motion on table for the amended
Amendment here
ought to pass on the bill
um would you like to speak to your
emotions please
it was quite a bit of discussion a good
discussion on this bill
process
um
assistance of Representative
representative Ford
um we have put together this amendment
which I will
um everyone has a copy of
talking and just to go through it
um
the first section remains in terms of uh
the burden of proof in due processary
and in the amendment that
new sections with establishing the
committee
it would have three three members from
the house in one minute remember from
the Senate uh and patients and duties
start out with
the beginning of the process which is
the child's fine requirements to provide
a and then it goes into the actual IDP
um where I see
it was testimony and
some things that work well in the it
meetings and sometimes things do not
work well
so that is a I think a good
place to look at the process and the
roles of the members uh of the team and
um the actual consent that's required by
parents for uhp plan
requirements and also the
New Hampshire process for Speed
resolution
they would examine the supports for
parents which is certainly been an issue
with its testimony that we've heard and
the um
[Music]
to know all the requirements and
regulations but what support is
available for them
in addition to the legal
supports that are often need for the due
process hearings
um also you would take a look at the
Department of Education monitoring of
the process both
iepa and state law requirements uh as
well as parental complaints that are
made to the Department
it's important would be to look at uh
opportunities or best practices in
dispute resolution
some information on other state
that seem to have
separate
supports for parents
in due process
hearings and uh all the way up through
the complaint process
and then certainly take testimony and
consult with the parents and state
agencies and other experts as required
and then developed a report with any
recommendations for improving the
process and I think that that works as a
key thing that really the entire
committee wanted to
people forward on
to help the situation uh testimony tag
and the report will be required by the
first of November
so it's basically that's the uh the
amendment and um
I think that it does strengthen the bill
and uh
quite a bit of support in the heart to
pass as amended motion thank you very
much representative Mullen would you
like to meet the second would you like
to add anything to this uh just to Echo
what representative cordelli has said I
think it's important for parents to
recognize that the entire committee
heard their plea as they came forward
and that we are all in agreement that we
would like to do a deeper dive to see
where the root of the problem is and how
the Department of Education can assist
and what we can do as a legislative body
to sort of lessen this perception that
we've got a David and Goliath situation
here and work towards making sure that
special education students in New
Hampshire all have their needs met
thank you
any further discussion on
the amendment for HB 581
not CD for the hands could you please
call the academics we're now reporting
on the amendment for 581 beds with
numbers
yes on Amendment one two three
uh
yes
representative ball yes representative
Allard yes representative yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Hobson yes representative
yes
representative Ford yes
representative Leon yes
representative Sony yes
representative Myler yes
yes
then Shaw yes or no yes
represent Tanner yes yes
representative Mullen yes repented legs
yes
representative yes
representative ledge Yes
I need zero shall we put it on
conscience yes
just okay
is there a second representative
so we have a motion on floor for to talk
to pass 581 with Amendment
0823h Madam any discussion for the
discussion
not see enhancement or representative
cordelli yes representative yes
representative Valor yes representative
yes it's been a muppet yes
yes representative yes
94. yes instead of Leon yes yes
representative yes yes
yes
representative yes
okay with everybody
consent is fine yes
yeah I just wanted to thank everybody
because I think this bill is a good
representative of how we could all be
working together
testify uh in the Senate on House Bill
242.
and uh
wanted to collect some discussion about
this
before we take a emotion
um
the number of us were talking and it
seems there is no we have bills every
year on uh Cooperative school districts
um
he had a study committee I think about
three years ago
also and it's been a difficult
difficult to pass it because of the
number of Cooperative school districts
and the differences in the approach and
contracts within those districts
and uh
this bill
is simpler than some but
um
I would look to uh representative
uh yes yes Mr chair I would move that we
retain house bill 152.
um I believe that that you've addressed
the point that we these are very unique
situations this is something where
Perhaps Perhaps this this change would
benefit some school Cooperative school
districts but there's so many different
ways that this is implemented across the
state that doing the subjects and all of
this all of the Cooperative school
districts to this one solution just
doesn't doesn't quite seem to make sense
we should retain this work on it and see
if we can do something that will address
address the broader concerns
um
any comments from other committee
members about the retained motion on
round 52.
thank you very much Mr chair so I'm
surprised actually that the motion is to
retain
um on this because uh it seemed that
during the um during the hearing we
heard from the the sponsor but we also
heard from um former member uh Jim
Belanger speaking about the importance
of it and from school boards Association
that that that this this doesn't add a
new
um you know wrinkle to uh to Cooperative
school districts it basically is a it
it's a
[Music]
um
it's it's an amendment to a procedure
that already applies to uh to
Cooperative school districts and and uh
you know simply ads I think the the
condition that um that when the current
formula is passed you know to continue
doing it that uh that that that sets up
the uh The Five-Year review time frame
um as it would if it was a had been
amended so uh you know I think that I I
guess I'm not quite sure what the what
the issue is you know this isn't the
hill I'm gonna die on but I don't
understand the uh motion to retain
yes I I don't understand either this is
this is a simple bit it's already in law
and all it does is just allow them to
continue with the present contract
um because the way it's stated in law it
just says that you know they have to
change something so what they've had to
do in the past is is to add a dollar to
the budget or or take it all out or
whatever
so that they could pass it because it's
a good agreement they like it they want
to keep it but the way it's stated in
law it says that they have to change
something
and so all this does is take that away
and and I think
I I don't understand I thought this
would be a no-brainer on campus oh it
kind of confuses me too and I know that
representative delandi was very uh is
very knowledgeable in this area uh in in
the past that they thought uh always uh
very strong
education supporter and everything and I
think he knows uh his uh his business
very well and he was
very vehement about having this pass
because it's just necessary to conduct
business
so I'm surprised at the retain also
thank you
uh thank you Mr chair
um I worked at Kearsarge which is a
Cooperative District of
um seven towns and uh if if the formula
could be revised every year
it just doesn't add continuity to to the
whole school district
um things have worked out really well
we've been uh in existence
um since 1970 and had a couple of
changes to the formula over over that
time but I think this bill should be
ought to pass it's it puts it in in
writing kind of clarifies the current
law thank you
places
yeah I actually have to admit I'm a
little surprise when we were retaining
it as well because it didn't actually
change anything on the funding formulas
or anything because all it does is
like they were saying keep them from
having to make a change of one dollar so
what I'm wondering is if anybody knows
of any school districts that this any
Cooperative school districts that would
not like this
foreign
[Music]
thank you Mr chair appreciate it
um I I would concur with with uh the
fellow speakers uh representative McGee
brought this as a one-line change who
doesn't change the thing except make
that uh School Board uh more more
cooperative for Cooperative it saves a
whole lot of town meeting uh snags it
doesn't do a thing except help it and
you have two Town moderators both spoken
favor no one's complaining about the
bill I mean at some point when people
bring bills to the legislation and ask
for help to their own little towns they
know the issue it doesn't hurt a thing
you know it makes no sense that we just
retain this you know you're causing a
problem or it doesn't need to be
prevention
further
fashion
um
it's your turn
yes this is the most internment
oh okay
we've had a request for our pockets from
a representative here in the committee
room
um is that okay with uh
to people on tune yes
uh five minute recess
great Mel do you want to caucus uh sure
all right well uh we'll uh drop into our
room too so disconnect from uh from this
one back at 9 35.
yes all right sounds good Glenn
thank you
foreign
uh
session
um
[Music]
this one
for a second
someone's on a hot mic
can you hear us okay
um
thank you thank you Mr chair I would
like to withdraw my motion
all right that was the retained motion
yes I'd like to withdraw my retained
motion on House Bill 150. okay I never
know that uh
yeah so withdraw my second
okay may I make a motion
sure I'd like to move on to pass
okay I'll second that okay great
so the new motion on the floor is uh
it's
expressing its Shaw
and the second spot
further discussion on uh
that past Amendment Representative no I
think what I stated before it's in my
correction uh to make life easier for
Cooperative School Board districts and I
think they have enough problems not
getting everybody on board and I think
that this is certainly uh a minor thing
that we can do that that helps as
president Tanner said continuity very
important and and Cooperative districts
unless there's some major change like a
Dropout or something
so uh past experience
that's it okay
uh representative
um I I agree that that this we might as
well go ahead and pass this that'll help
out some of the school districts and it
just seem like it'll harm any others
thank you
but any further comments from
those out there in Dreamland
I've seen none
master
yes we are looking at the pass on House
Bill 152.
uh representative cordelli I'm sorry
representative bone yes
representative Aller yes representative
yes
representative Moffett yes
representative Thompson yes
representative Andres yes representative
board yes
yes yes
yes
Allison yes they're Mullen yes
19-0
yes
right now
thank you
great thank you everybody
the next bill
um like to take up is uh house bills
discrimination
uh
Mr chair can you repeat the number
please
thank you
I would like to make a motion to retain
house bill 198.
I'll second that
okay thank you
we'd like to uh sure comments
according to this bill was based on some
federal
um wording and regulation
and we have decided that it is
it could be
worded differently and better and we
need to look at this issue a little
longer so
we thought we'd retain it and see if we
can what we can do about it basically
uh not just concurrent uh representative
thank you representative Milo uh thank
you Mr chair uh typically
when we retain a bill
there's usually support
however this particular bill
from our caucus perspective
is so onerous
that it's our intent to vote no on the
retention of the bill because we believe
that it should be Ito
this is an unusual move on the part of
our caucus but it represents I think the
emotion that we have
about the need for this bill not to pass
in any form whatsoever and even be
worked on whatsoever because of the
nature of the bill and the vast
testimony that we've had
from people who are in opposition to
this bill that we've basically feel that
the guidelines of the nhiaa which allows
for local school districts to make the
determination of transgender athletes
and that's we support that proposition
so our caucus will be voting no on this
right retention because of our feelings
about the essence of this particular
proposal thank you
it's representative
discussion
aggressive scanner
thank you Mr chair
um I feel the same way uh this bill is
unnecessary it's misguided it's
misinformed it's discriminatory and it's
dangerous
um in committee we received no report or
testimony that there's any issue of
safety or or fairness in New Hampshire
Youth Sports from the current inclusion
of transgender athletes
we did hear testimony that this bill
would deny access and inclusion of
transgender girls and women in sports
programs
and it would adversely affect the mental
and physical health by excluding
isolating and targeting transgender
girls and women
there's no need to interfere with the
current inclusion policies of 50 of our
high schools and organizations like the
nhiaa and the NCAA who are the
organizations that oversee the fairness
and safety of sports competition in
schools and currently have inclusion
policies
this bill is asking us
to seek an exception to our current
discrimination laws I think all New
Hampshire students need and deserve
protections against discrimination as
defined in our statute RSA 193 colon 38
including gender identity thank you
all right thank you representative
Tanner and chairman laddin joined us so
uh I'll turn on the range of us
okay great
um
yes I do Mr chair thank you so much
um I representative Tana's worries were
eloquent and representative Milo's
philosophy is accurate
um I would just add that I I know I'm
someone new to the game only two
sessions in but I do recall that the
retained bill is to make improvements
this bill came two years ago it was bad
then
and we voted down it wasn't approved
this year it's bad now and it should be
voted down and not retained thank you
further discussion uh representative
yeah thank you very much Mr chair so I
agree with with everything my esteemed
colleagues have um have have said about
um about this and why we should vote no
on the on the motion to retain and vote
Yes on a motion to um to itl this um uh
this bill you know just looking at the
the the significant testimony I think we
had 31 people testify the only people
um testifying and support were the prime
sponsor and um and a person who said she
was representing all girls in sports
which is just an outrageous
um comment and uh and completely
inaccurate so so uh for that reason and
then compounded by the fact that there
was a blue she tally of 24 inch support
and
1135 people in opposition
um to this bill I think um I think this
bill certainly warrants being being
dispatched today as um as as itl
thank you
further discussion
I'm not see any
so uh
would you do the honors
yes
I'll spell 198.
uh retained
uh
[Music]
sorry okay
coffee wasn't strong enough yet
just some more
uh representative cordelli yes
representative ball yes
representative Aller yes
representative yes representative
Moffett yes representative yes
representative Andrus yes representative
board
he's muted
yes
representative Leon yes representative
yes Representative no
representative
representative Shaw no represent Cornell
no representative Tanner no absolutely
not representative Ellison no
representative Mullen no representative
light nope
new
I'm here I'm here yes
11 9.
[Music]
hey uh so we the bill that we just did
is going to be retained uh we're gonna
move on now to HB 464.
difficult
yes okay on on 464
um we're still waiting on an amendment
from Mary Ellen okay so we'll jump past
this one
computers in the other room so I'm
working on representative's computer
right now so so we're going to do uh
move to three points yeah
bill so we're going to go to HB 321 at
this point in time
okay
I've got an education by the way is a
way way behind they're still on their
first bill uh hb110
okay this bill requires school districts
to submissions
gifted students who have a motion
represents here I'd like to move OTP uh
with an amendment
okay
is there a second to that motion
it's in shop
yes okay thank you so we have a motion
on the table to uh improve uh 321 with
Amendment uh made by represent
representative uh Moffett second by
representative Shaw uh
do have the the amendment number
representative Moffett
yes I do uh 2021
Dash
zero five three seven h
ate zero five three seven
yes
um
[Music]
uh
around here
thank you Mr chair uh yes uh the the
amendment
um to the original bill has two changes
that were recommended by the chair and
others simply adds two words it adds the
word talented to gifted and talented and
it adds the words programs to policies
and procedures
so that is the amendment
um and on the on the the bill itself uh
I would just say that this is a bill
that this committee heard in uh 2018 it
was referred to interim study
uh seven member interim study committee
uh
overwhelmingly to uh recommend OTP it
came to the foot this full uh
Committee in September of 2018 in the
full committee uh the motion is made by
representative Shaw seconded by
representative Mary geil and the full
committee uh at that time voted uh
to recommend OTP of course uh this was a
September of 2018 and the bill did not
have a chance to go to the Full House
and then um it whatever I was not here
the subsequent term I'm not sure what
happened there so I I do want to say
that uh uh when we refer a built interim
study and folks take a lot of time and
meet several times and come up with a
recommendation I would hope that we
would honor or or uh respect the interim
study uh committee's work uh otherwise
uh why would someone want to be on uh
interim study and again uh it's a very
very short Bill all it does is it just
asks
uh districts to share what they do if
anything for a essentially best
practices folder to share good ideas and
that's about it there is no requirement
to analyze data uh it's just basically
sharing uh ideas for a best practices
folder and that's that's it
no I just concur with uh representative
okay
any further discussion
um the audience
thank you thank you Mr chair
um when this when this was uh presented
to us two years ago I supported it I'm
not going to do that this time the
reason for that it's not because I'm
against the gifted and talented is that
it it has no purpose uh we don't know
where are you and this is going to land
in the Department of Education it's
going to be put into a file nothing's
going to happen to it it's another
activity that school districts will have
to have
there's no really definition of what is
a gifted and talented student I mean we
talked about this uh in the hearing in
the hearing when we talked about you
know does this mean that the star
athlete should be a gifted and talented
should that be put in there uh should a
an extremely gifted musician be put in
there there's no definition to what this
is all about and so until we have I
think a further clarification of exactly
the intent of the file
and give some guidance to school
districts as it relates to what is
gifted and talented I just think that
this is just another busy work for
school districts to send to the
Department of Education that will really
land in the file of indecision and
inaction and I don't think it's
necessary thank you
previously
um no no go with somebody else I'm sorry
um
yes
I don't see a problem with the school
deciding who is talented or gifted and
if they decide that a particularly
talented musician is talented and they
came up with a way of helping that child
to become the best they could be by
whatever means they did whether somehow
finding a an orchestra for them to play
with or whatever and they send that so
that other schools know hey this is what
we did and this really helped this kid
so maybe you want to consider doing the
same thing I don't see a problem with
that
uh thank you Mr chair uh having worked
at the Department of Education for 41
years uh I I have to tell you that this
particular approach to an educational
issue of school districts summarizing in
narrow using their own definitions and
sending a report to the Department of
Education which goes into a file folder
or in this case maybe onto a website uh
does a little if nothing to focus on the
particular issue here around gifted and
talented uh as far as I'm concerned this
is like a feel-good bill and it gets us
to saying this is better than nothing if
we really are serious about this issue
and helping school districts approach it
we would be uh supporting staff a staff
person at the Department of Education
that they have in the past who was
significant in helping districts
approach this particular issue so I'll
be voting against the bill
yeah my thinking is a little bit
different on this and the reason I
supported it
I have had uh
principles in Manchester approach me
uh especially one who continuously has
said when are we going to do something
at the state level about getting to
students
and the only reason that I think this is
good is a
it's it's a beginning
what it would do is submit reports which
would be placed on file and I can see in
the next legislative session or in in
the next term
Someone putting in a bill that will
expand on uh the gifted and talented
aspect of student achievement
and at that point someone could say well
do we have any idea of what anybody has
been doing in in the state about this
you can say well actually we have an
informal file that was bio uh because of
legislation that was passed in 2021
that has you know a sporadic uh uh
reporting of what's been done around the
state
so we can start with that and just get
an idea about what's going on around the
state and work from there so that's my
way of thinking about it it's probably
here we go my favorite word demented but
I I think this is
um just uh something to say well you
know something is there let's build on
it and and that's my field because I
don't think at this point uh with the
cobit and all the other things that have
been going on
uh we don't need to throw something else
out there right now but I think this is
a good beginning a resource thank you
thank you Mr chairman I'd just like to
add to in our school district in the
past we've sent our we'll say gifted
math students down to the elementary
school to help the different the
elementary school
I mean that kind of thing might like to
share also in the case of athletes of
course why not if you have a gifted
soccer player in high school that's
really great why not send to the Middle
School to help that soccer team I see
nothing wrong with that at all uh
school and schools can share their own
personal experience we did this we did
this there's the principles Association
that they that can be used for sharing
all this information there's all kinds
of teachers associations that
that exists that these these things can
be shared and the school board
Associates all these things can somehow
be shared not just the doe school
districts can share with their own
colleagues across the state so it's
being done now and I I see no problem
with athletes musicians actors or
anything that's gifted honest you know
um
you know going going to from one school
to another helping so even across
districts if you want to do that so I
see no problem with this is I think it's
great let's find out what other school
districts are doing and share that
information
thank you Mr chair
I think at the high school level uh
there's a lot of things for gifted
athletes and gifted math students AP
courses and different times of
competition for them to to participate
in
we um in my school district we had a
gifted and talented program for the
elementary and middle school where I
think it's really really needed
it was sometimes there and sometimes not
and the biggest thing biggest difference
in it was not that we didn't have people
who had ideas about how to run this or
what to do or to send students down uh
to the elementary school and help out it
was money and time
uh that was the big issue and I think it
will always be the big issue for public
schools when testing came in required
testing and No Child Left Behind came in
when
school funding started dropping uh
gifted and talented was one of the first
programs to go so I support the programs
but I don't think this is the way to
encourage schools to do them the the
schools that don't have them probably
can't afford them and don't have the
time within their schedule to meet all
the requirements that we put on them and
then offer this kind of program so I'll
be voting no against
um this particular piece of legislation
but know that I firmly support uh gifted
and talented or a similar type of
program in the elementary and middle
school thank you
let's do it I've worked in a good path
thank you Mr chair um just a quick thing
I listening to representative Bowen are
talking about the associations and the
share experiences I concur with them 100
and I think they're that all those
associations are an opportunity for
schools to share uh collectively however
when you add a requirement uh to every
single school superintendent to submit
another report into doe
um that's a whole different task and and
I don't see much value in that uh where
there's no there's no current direction
on what's going to happen to those
things but the utilizing the
associations the Teachers Association
the afd the Nea the school bus
Association that's terrific that's all
voluntary and now we just add another
task and a tough time of year
um that has no substance to Local
Schools superintendents thank you thank
you uh representative Leon uh thank you
Mr chair
if it's such a one of my concerns is
that right now lower lower aged children
those in elementary school may not be
may not have the same opportunities to
move forward because if a teacher or the
school is concerned that there may not
be educational opportunities for them
once they reach the high school level if
they accelerate too much in the earlier
grades they may be concerned about
offering further enrichment this is an
area where if every teacher who is
concerned about this is contacting the
superintendent that's going to take more
time than allowing them simply to
acquire the Department of Education or
simply query the superintendent's office
to find out what their individual school
policy is this is an area where we need
to make sure that our young minds are
challenged because young minds that
aren't challenged become disruptive and
it is a lot better to make sure that
they can get some new opportunities
pursue this and make sure that the
teachers aren't afraid that they're
going to get topped out in calculus
because they're not aware that that
there's a arrangement for some of these
more accelerated students to take some
classes at the college level if they
really do excel in math
thank you
yeah I'd like to point out that the rest
of the world rigorous that promotes and
cultivates gifting students I think we
need to get started on that
thank you uh representative
thank you Mr chair uh just a couple of
questions I was wondering if um it's a
small district and it makes a report and
it becomes quite clear from the report
who
is being denominated gifted in whatever
category do parents have the ability to
uh appeal and claim that their child is
gifted and ought to be included as well
um and I ask that because right now uh
in the report as it stands or in the
legislation proposed as stands there are
no standards
there's nothing that offers any
definitions and so I was just thinking I
was reading how um my high school local
high school Conan High School the girls
basketball team just won their second
straight state championship second
straight undefeated season uh do you
name one person as gifted on that team
or do you name the entire team as gifted
um and if you name one person or it's
clear that one person is denominated as
gifted because again it's a small
District
um and in the report it could be pretty
clear as to who it is
um do the other parents of the girls the
other girls have a right of appeal to
say well my child is gifted as well
um and contributed to the team
um and so I'm just wondering how that
would be handled thank you
that's a question for the sponsor by the
way okay uh we'll follow him in a second
uh
yes I'm supportive of this bill and
partly because I didn't think we should
offer a
um requirement at this stage I noted
when their schools were all reporting on
the what they did and what they'd when
they spoke to us about various Things No
One mentioned the gifted at all
and I remember when my children were in
school there was a great deal of
difficulty in getting things that got
very bright perhaps overactive but
nonetheless kids engaged in things that
kept them out of trouble
it was all kinds of support as in
Varsity athletes and all that for
athletics The Talented toe
but there was nothing for the talented
kid it was nothing for the really bright
kid and this was a
shall we say undemanding and keep in
mind I'm a former English Prof so adding
one essay to someone's life is not what
I call an onerous requirement
you may have suspected that already when
you were in college but nonetheless
it's just not that difficult to say well
we're doing this and this and this and
this and this and we're having some
success with two of them and not so much
with the other all we're asking for is
is anybody paying attention
because the next step is then to move to
a requirement which is over the
requirements that representative lay and
others have suggested that a very
specific and qualify and we work out a
definition that excludes the athletes
because they have things taking care of
them
but they are the other kids the kids
that watch them being given sweaters
every year and so what do I get
I don't get a sweater if I'm good in
Latin I don't get anything I'm chopped
change chop soup whatever
nothing so yeah some jump change and
Chopsticks and uh chopped liver I guess
it is but at any rate
the point being that this is an
invitation to sort of alert them that
we're concerned about this
it doesn't require anything much of them
a simple
very short in-class essay would suffice
but we got nothing
this is better than nothing
that's my point
yeah thank you Mr chair uh and thank you
representative Ford for your uh your
comments uh I I can tell that you you
can sense the intent behind this uh yeah
I do understand briefly to
representative lay and also to uh
representative Milo's earlier comments
um by Design By Design the uh the
warning of this bill uh describes gifted
and talented in the broadest possible
terms so that localities can have a
discussion locally as to what they feel
uh constitutes a population or students
who are underserved and deserve some
attention that they have not been
getting
so uh yeah by Design we we do not want
to prescriptively tell districts uh who
or what or who is is gifted uh should we
leave that to the localities in terms of
uh reporting uh it could be done by an
email uh with an attachment uh so it's
certainly not an onerous requirement to
report anything
um and the sad thing is that many
perhaps most districts uh do nothing or
next to nothing in this area
uh two terms ago when we spent some time
researching this with Jennifer four I
mentioned this during the hearing New
Hampshire may be very well maybe the
worst state in the country in terms of
what it does in terms of paying
attention to for having programs for
so-called gifted and talented students
so this uh this measure is simply in the
beauty of this measure which some folks
have picked up on uh more than others is
that this will require a conversation uh
a discussion in every District in in the
State uh where in many districts nothing
is happening because of this legislation
should have moved forward then there
will be a discussion locally as to what
is happening and the notion that the
best practices folder At Doe will will
go nowhere I I profoundly disagree with
that I think once the word gets out that
there is a so-called best practices
folder I think there's going to be a
wonderful sharing of ideas and energy in
in conversation on this uh overdue
subject so uh yeah I think that it's
time that we take a baby step uh in this
direction and shine a light where it
needs to be shined
yes I am I would like to follow up on
what representative Shaw said
whenever we start any study or any law
or anything any new bill what we hear
all the time is well what's being done
now
and we don't know what's being done now
so before we can follow up on this
before we can even if we're doing a
study committee on this wouldn't it be
nice for the study committee to have
this information already as a starting
point if we want to put a bill in in the
future as far as what we can do for
gifted you know the first question
people are going to ask is well what are
we doing now so let's do this so we know
what we're doing now so that in the
future when we follow up with whatever
we're going to do we have this
information and we're ready to go
forward instead of having to start from
the beginning and find out what we're
doing now thank you thank you
representative
thank you Mr chair So based on that I
would argue then that you should
establish a study committee because
right now with the sort of information
you're going to collect it is going to
be well nigh useless because again you
will have no idea what the standards are
that that individual districts are using
because you're not requiring or asking
for what those standards are You're
simply going to get a list of certain
practices but we have no idea who
they're applicable to how people are
determined how people are chosen in
different districts you're just going to
get a list of activities and that in and
of itself is not particularly useful
you're collecting only a portion of the
data that you would need to engage in a
serious study of this issue I agree that
the the issue needs to be studied I
agree that I would love to see schools
do more of this but if we're going to
collect data collect it in a whole
fashion okay do do do a serious
collection not this this is just simply
going to be
it's going to be woefully incomplete I
guess it's just simply the way I'll put
it so um I think it's a it's a measure
that feels good but I don't necessarily
think that it will yield uh much
particularly useful information and
you're just going to have to go back and
do it again if you ever want to engage
in a serious study of it thank you
uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
representative lay for your perspective
on this I know that coming from your
background the standards and the
criteria are crucial for this
I Come From Another point of view
in the gifted program in California
there was assumed to be a certain
percentage of students that would be
considered gifted there was a criteria
based on test scores and they limited
how many students could be tested both
in the high socio economic schools and
in the low socioeconomic schools when
those when more children were allowed to
test they found that more children were
performing at the gifted level however
that had been suppressed because they
assumed that only a certain percentage
truly were gifted right now if we
address this without those standards
without those criteria we don't need to
have something that is very costly or
very time consuming if we encourage
these children whose parents think that
they're gifted or the children think
that they're gifted to
to challenge themselves to perhaps take
on work maybe let them take the textbook
from the next year home and take a look
at it and see what they can do maybe
encourage them to read outside of their
reading level in the month write some
reports in their spare time children
children love to learn and we need to
make sure that we are not teaching that
love of learning out of them
right if they can be challenged and they
can find those subjects that interest
them it's amazing how quickly Children
of the children can progress both those
that are on the gifted spectrum and
those that we don't really view as
gifted if we can challenge these
students if we can see what happens when
we give them the opportunity to learn at
their own pace uh ahead I think we might
see some amazing things and we might see
even higher performance from all of our
students when they see their peers
really do get an opportunity and they're
not just told to sit down look at the
wall and pretend like you're not done
with your project you know maybe that's
just coming from my personal opinion I I
was reading 1984 in my second grade
classroom and my teacher thought that I
I wasn't wasn't
um
I wasn't gifted enough to be tested and
and I think that all children should
have the opportunity to prove or improve
their Merit and if they fall short that
doesn't mean that there there it doesn't
mean that they they aren't smart it just
means that they've realized that there
is a challenge in front of them and they
have the opportunity to confront that
and get stronger
thank you Mr chair
um my I'm gonna I'm gonna Veer away from
the philosophical and back towards the
pragmatic a little so I guess this is a
question for representative moffatt
um
my question is have you spoken to
anybody at the Department of Education
with regards to representative Ellison's
previous comments that there used to be
a gifted and talented person or a person
well uh
truly there will be gifted and talented
people at the Department of Education
but a person dedicated to managing uh
gifted and talented programming uh have
you spoken to anybody to find out sort
of what has happened in the past and
where these reports might be most useful
uh and if so is there a person in place
now who would actually be receiving
these reports and answering the
inquiries of school districts who would
be in touch with the doe
yeah thank you representative Mullen for
your question uh sure uh I did have
conversations uh uh two terms ago when
we put this together initially with a
number of Folks At Doe
um my understanding is historically in
the past there there was uh an
individual or a position there that at
least in part-time status uh focused on
this area and that no longer exists as I
understand it uh so should this move
forward and should these reports uh come
to doe they'll be at the doe to uh do
what they wanted with the information
um I think that to your point
um once if assuming this moves forward
once all this information comes to doe I
think this could be an impetus for doe
to uh revive this position
um and I think that would be a good
thing but again that's again up to doe
and again there is no mandate here
there's no spending
um it's very simple and I think that uh
only good things could come from this
add doe to your point and also locally I
hope that answers your question somewhat
somewhat but thank you for at least
attempting an answer representative
Moffett
thank you
thank you Mr chair if you made a lot I'd
like to ask if I could represent Allison
a clarification on his statement
yeah certainly
thank you uh president Olson you spoke
about
um the doe uh receiving all this
information and I understand the process
that representative Mafia was talking
about my question is
um I when there is a file or a program
like this coming into doe do they record
how many times is are viewed or other
people look at it so you have an actual
idea of of high school you're actually
using this these types of documents
uh if there's a person there who's in
charge of the program or the concept
that then yes someone is monitoring that
and trying to sort of facilitate
communication between the people asking
questions and the people filing reports
in the absence of that person uh it's my
uh opinion that the reports go into a
file and they stay there and there's no
interaction
thank you thank you representative uh
Cordell I appreciate the opportunity
sure uh representative
thank you Mr chairman Mr further
um every school every school every
person in the school model pretty much
was gifted at one for example my
granddaughter graduated in 2010 as well
Victorian and if you asked her if she
was gifted she would say no but she
relied on other gifted students to get
there she relied on a math gifted
student one of a set of twins one was
gifted in math in one of 2011 but
identity but anyway she relied on him
for her math
she relied on other people I mean and
people relied on her people know who is
gifted and the whole school knows who
was gifted so it's not not a secret it's
not how many people know and nothing in
the bill says identified they had to
give a name you can say we send students
from there to here and students Mentor
other students and that's what was being
done so
uh by nominating the whole team and
whatnot yeah the whole team's gifted in
other words if everybody gets 100 points
a game yeah but the point is
it gifted students also rely on other
gifted students I mean it they all work
together they know who all is gifted
everybody in the in our high school
knows who's gifted and and nobody argues
the point I've never seen any parents
take my kid just to gift it now I mean
kids know who's gifted and they go go
that way and nothing in here said you
have to be named you just identify
identify as student a so
the whole thing is schools know
teachers know parents know who's gifted
so you know so let's try and help the
gifted students get be more gifted I
have a thing by allowing him to go take
some college courses and math if they
want to I know uh UNH and Manchester for
years really offering evening courses at
UNH to Manchester for high school kids
to get further credits and math so
that's one of the ways you can you can
do it like my granddaughter she had five
years of math and she's not a math
genius but yeah she took half with what
she relied on and gifted students for
some of her help so thank you
thanks very much Mr chair and I I just
wanted to sort of follow up on what
representative Bohm was just um
um talking about and and you know I I I
do agree with a lot of what's been been
said this morning I guess I'm I'm
struggling a bit with the uh with you
know the terminology of you know gifted
and talented versus I I mean which is
what represent bone was talking about
but he's he's saying everybody knows
who's who's gifted
um but but I I think at the same time
you could sort of substitute that well
everybody knows who's good at math I
mean I was the go-to guy in math and
chemistry in in high school and people
knew I was good at that stuff because I
like that stuff and I put a lot of time
into that stuff and and um uh and and so
I you know I I don't think
I don't think I was born you know
knowing how to do you know elliptical
integrals or anything like that I mean I
think I learned how to do that by
putting in the effort
um but and but so I guess my my question
to represent boam if he'll take the
question is what's where are you where
are you drawing the line in terms of
gifted versus being good at it
if you want to uh that's fine
that's that's a sort of a gray area yeah
I mean like I mentioned my granddaughter
she was good at hard work
and she was good at fact knowing who was
there are I mean at the gray areas
somebody really worked hard gifted and
working hard and they maybe then be able
to Mentor other kids uh some kids are
good at math I mean they just zoom no
matter what you give them they they'll
know it right from
when they first started doing arithmetic
I mean some kids are good at at uh
English they can write all kinds of
reports and whatnot uh but yeah the gray
area there isn't any yeah working hard
at something may make you gifted I mean
so you know it's a hard question to
answer but people know people know who
to go to just like you said who to go to
hey how do you I do this because anybody
pretty much in the high school
especially just keeping the smaller one
even bigger one uh know who in that
class they can ask questions of and not
maybe but yeah they're gifted at working
hard I mean I don't see any problem
yeah so just a quick quick follow-up Mr
chair so um so Ralph I I absolutely
agree with a lot of what you just um
said there and um and uh and and I I
think there's good intentions behind
you know all of this here
um uh I am concerned about about
unintended consequences when when using
you know specific terms like gifted and
talented and and um and what what that's
encouraging or not encouraging and and I
guess um you know once I know we're
we're you know we're debating an
amendment right now I think um 7 16. I'm
sorry uh five uh 537 I think
um and uh and uh and you know I'm hoping
to be able to offer another amendment
that I think in the spirit of the uh of
the bill is as proposed
um really sort of you know broadens the
um the the approach here to talk about
what representative bone was saying
which is which is encouraging people to
work hard and put in the effort and and
that's really ultimately what leads to
uh you know success in school and
success in life and um you know I'm not
trying to you know I I I think I think
we're we're all looking at the best
intentions surrounding this um
um um this this legislation but um I'm
hoping to have the opportunity to uh to
offer that Amendment um uh after we get
past this
Cornell
yeah this conversation has just
um reinforced my idea that this is way
too vague from listening to everybody
talking I have no idea now what
superintendents or school districts
would be expected to send in is what
they're offering for gifted
students at according to representative
boehm it could be we offer that the
really smart kids help the ones that
want to work really hard to become
gifted or are we actually putting in
that a School District offers
you know advanced placement courses or
the opportunity to participate in
running star or a theater program or an
advanced chorus program
it it's just so vague to me what is
going to be expected that I don't know
that what's going to be sent in and put
in the folder will be of any use of
anybody that's going to look up to get
ideas it's I I think it needs more
definition and and I structure of
what we're looking for if it's of any
use at all
that's all
right thank you president Tanner
thank you Mr chair uh before I spoke
about money and time and also the fact
that you know this program is really
like uh representative Leon said is
really for should be for the elementary
and middle school students who at some
point just just give up they they you
know they want they want to be enriched
they want to have the ability to be
enriched what we're talking about most
of the time here is like the robotics
program the dual enrollment program
that's all for the high school kids and
and that takes a you know work and and
initiative to get into those programs
and if you have it you know you're
you're going to seek out those programs
and if you're in a school district that
has a lot of money
there's going to be a lot of
opportunities for you if you're in a
school district with not a lot of money
there there's not a lot of opportunity
for you but down at the elementary
school if you're a teacher and you have
25 30 kids in class and you've got one
kid that's running around and
hyperactive and seems to finish the
workbook stuff really fast
those are the kids we want to grab and
give enrichment programs to and I'm not
sure
we even have any identification for that
at this point and I would suggest that
if as we search into this uh
issue more that we stopped talking about
high school where there is all kinds of
opportunities and really look at
elementary and middle schools
um where this program would be uh key to
to growth for a lot of students I think
thank you
representative Leon
thank you Mr chair this is one of the
areas where we do have great
opportunities and such schools in the
state and high school level and you're
right that in some communities they
don't have those same opportunities
but when if the children are excited
about what they can do it they can
probably work with teachers that are
interested in order to be able to build
these programs at their schools if
they're not aware of what's happening
and how it's being done in these more
exceptional school districts it's a lot
harder for them to create a on a limited
budget in uh in rural school districts
if they're able to work together see
what those opportunities are and start
developing their skills this is going to
push everybody forward I mean you look
at Honey Escalante and what he did in LA
in the public schools with those
students people didn't expect those
children those students to be able to
perform that way but but the opportunity
was there and they seized on it if you
expose them to the opportunity the
potential of what can happen and what
they can do it's it's amazing what you
can see and a lot of these kids in these
in these four school districts don't
really know exactly what can happen even
here in New Hampshire and it's I don't
think that it's a matter
where they would love to say that
they're being left out of the
opportunity I think that if you can see
this see what can happen and make it
happen in your community that's going to
make them a lot stronger that's going to
make them Future Leaders that's the sort
of thing that can motivate these gifted
students in order to bring about these
opportunities and develop them and
letting these students have a look at
what's happening across the state
perhaps in a in a in a club for gifted
students with one of the teachers
directing it they could they could
create a framework and I think that if
we crowdsource it even to these gifted
students in the elementary and middle
school ages this this could bring really
amazing opportunities and I think that
it would develop a lot of different
skills for them while they work on these
projects and just developing their own
program for gifted would be a phenomenal
research resource and a phenomenal
learning opportunity thank you uh
representative
yeah we'll keep talking about no
definition but there is a definition a
student identified as having unique
academic artistic or athletic potential
according to assessments selected and
administered locally
and
um we always talk about local control
and local whatever but the other part of
that is as representative Leon said if
you start making very narrow definitions
of I mean it's something unique unique
academic artistic girl at athletic
potential that's all that is and if you
start making oh you have to have a
certain IQ or you have to have you're
limiting people and so I think
um making this any narrower
is
um is counterproductive because you
don't know where that's going to show up
who that's going to be What that
particular academic potential or
athletic or artistic potential is going
to be it may be somebody who's
affordable at academics but is a
fantastic artist
or a musician or whatever and the point
is for the school to come up with a plan
for that child for each one of those
children not for big ballpark fit in the
Box you know rules and guidelines but
this child what are we doing about this
child and by having the school and it
doesn't say elementary middle school
high school it just says every school
which will hit those elementary kids
it'll hit the middle school kids and the
high school kids and it just says do you
have a plan
and and and if you don't have a plan you
gotta write and say I don't have a plan
so maybe this will before they have to
go and say I don't have a plan they
might say hmm maybe I should come up
with a plan maybe I should look and see
what kids are have special talents in
any particular area and what I can do
for that child
thank you thank you representative
thank you uh representative cordelli
um I would first like to say that I hope
that the kind of inspirational
instruction that representative lecus is
referring to is going on in classrooms
all over New Hampshire regardless of how
many gifted students are in the
classroom or not but I can tell you that
the district I represent has a very
robust program for uh gifted and
talented students and that the key to
success uh at least partially uh relies
upon the staff in the building that have
been hired and dedicated to gifted and
talented instruction not the classroom
teacher we have Personnel in every
Elementary School that are dedicated to
teaching gifted and talented Youth and
offering enrichment opportunities uh to
our students and until we're able to do
that in every school in New Hampshire
sure putting information into a folder
at the doe May in fact offer some
assistance but I don't think it's going
to even come close to offering the kind
of assistance that most districts need
thank you
you representative Tanner
I forgot to take my hand down sorry
about that
thank you there I go
thank you thank you Mr chair you know
it's interesting that this uh topic has
been one of the most substantive
conversations this committee has
entertained since we've been together
and I don't think there's any question
in any of our minds about the importance
of this particular topic and yet
at the Department of Education there is
no one
looking after this program
and I think that's a shame
so notwithstanding the issue that I said
earlier
that this needs more than just a file
for this information to go to and I
would hope that those persons from the
Department that are listening to this
conversation will begin to take notice
of how important this is and perhaps
take a little more attention to this
program thank you thank you
um
finalize uh this discussion with your
comments okay thank you Mr chair
um representative Mullen that sounds
like an amazing program that you have in
the Bedford schools is I'm curious if
that's something that's being shared
because that would be a great resource
for a lot of these other school
districts I'm also really encouraged
with this discussion uh right now it
seems that there's a big Trend to do
away with recognizing strong performance
in students I know we've done away with
letter grades and dairy and and it's
very inspiring to know that we still are
appreciating students and success and
student achievement especially because
if a student's sitting next next to
another student in class and that
student's gifted but nobody will
acknowledge that fact they might be
comparing themselves against their seat
mate and not realize that it's like a
kid who went to school with Shaquille
O'Neal questioning how they play
basketball
um it it does a service both for the
kids that get recognized for their
giftedness and the other ones that
realize they actually are sitting next
to a student he really understands the
subject and has an interesting
perspective on it because then they can
ask questions instead of feeling like
they might be less than just because
just because the student next to them
really understands calculus at an early
age or they just love organic chemistry
so this is something where it helps the
kids that are gifted it helps the kids
who are have the opportunity to work
with them and I'm I'm excited that if we
can get some more of this information
perhaps that's something where we can
get more of an effort at the department
level but let's find out what we're
doing let's get these best practices in
and and let's move this forward so that
we can do this and we can understand and
then then maybe the Department of
Education can do something for Gidget
students I would love to see that
thank you I think maybe uh we are ready
for a program environment
and
um
yes this is about to pass on the
amendment zero five three seven eight on
Hospital
321 representative cordelli yes
representative yes representative Fowler
yes representative likeness yes
representative Market yes representative
Hobson yes representative Andrus yes
therefore yes yes
foreign
I vote no
okay okay
no
elephant no Representative no that's the
same way nope instead of went pot no
representative lead yes
uh 12 8. amen
passes
okay
that was 11 acres
I'm sorry
okay uh
thanks very much Mr chair and um and I
hope um now would be an opportunity uh
and I hope we don't have to have uh you
know an hour-long discussion on it but I
would like to um to move um Amendment um
uh
2021-0752 offered by myself and
representative selson and Woodcock
um to hospital 321 and um it was sent um
uh I actually the the original draft of
that amendment was uh was sent several
days ago but there was a a typo uh in it
so 752 was uh was sent over to the um
the members of the committee this
morning and um uh so I'd like to move
that
I'll second that
okay we have we have a motion on the
floor uh made by uh rep San aluminol uh
second by uh who was the section
representative Tanner
um to move forward with uh
Amendment zero seven five two h
relative to 321.
okay open for discussion rep San Bruno
do you want to discuss your Amendment
I'd I'd love to introduce it just um
just briefly thank you very much Mr
chair so so uh as I mentioned earlier I
mean I largely agree with a lot of what
what what
um what members of the committee on on
both sides have been um been talking
about with respect to the uh the
intention behind house bill 321.
um and and that we're uh we're we're
really trying to you know encourage you
know students who are working hard and
doing doing well and um and uh for them
to uh to share that motivation and and
that that passion for whatever it is
whether it's math whether it's
basketball whether it's chemistry uh
with um with their with their fellow
classmates
um and um and you know what what what I
think um well what I what I know the uh
the amendment 752 does is um is is
really it just um it just moves uses
different terms where it replaces the
terms gifted and talid talented with uh
with terms that encourage student growth
and effort and um
um and so it uh you know basically adds
in Roman one findings that studies show
teaching people to have a growth mindset
which encourages a focus on effort helps
them to become High Achievers in school
and in life and that's actually
something that um that I think I I
quoted from back when uh back when we
held the hearing on on 321 uh last month
and um and then uh Roman 2
largely follows what uh what the what
the the previous Amendment and the
underlying bildo which is um uh require
um uh all New Hampshire Public Schools
to submit a narrative report to the
department talking about what policies
and procedures doesn't have the word
programs in there but Paul season
procedures are in place to encourage
student growth and effort and one of the
things that um that that you know that
that I think we've we've heard
um during the um you know during the
debate on the on the prior amendment I
mean
um uh representative Shaw talked about
well maybe we can you know offer
something in a next year in a subsequent
session to to expand
um uh this and really take a look at uh
growth and achievement and
representative Leon talked about how
young minds uh need to be challenged I I
agree with it I agree with that
um representative balm who who
um who I talked uh you know who were
talking about earlier talked about how
students are working hard and um and
this is all consistent with um with with
the amendment um you know before you
right now and um and just to sort of
remind people of um of I think some some
you know more updated uh uh studies in
the area so so you know things that sort
of you know take us out of the uh you
know the 1840s and bring us into you
know a more a better understanding a
more up-to-date understanding about how
the um uh how the brain works but uh you
know Carol dweck um you know has has
written in in her um you know her very
you know
um well-read um uh a very much read book
uh mindset that to the extent young
people believe they simply have a gift
that makes them intelligent or talented
they may not put put in the work
necessary to sustain that talent and
moreover the gifted label that many
students still receive and that their
parents relish may turn some children
into students who are overly cautious
and challenge avoid avoidant and um and
because they don't want to make mistakes
and um and put their um uh you know and
basically put their their gifted status
um you know in in Jeopardy and and and
you know when I was thinking about that
I was I also remembered um
you know years and years ago reading um
outliers by Malcolm Gladwell and and I'm
sure many of you have read read that
book and uh and you know the the whole
ten thousand hours thing and and I
remember very very much you know and you
know these quotes sort of stick with you
I don't know if it's verbatim but um you
know Gladwell talks about you know
anybody that um that that works um you
know
um you know three thousand hours a year
uh has never failed to to provide for
their family and and uh so he's he
developed this thing called the ten
thousand you know our rule where nobody
you know succeeds at a high level
um uh without both the the the talent
um and the um and getting some feedback
there
anybody yeah without without
without both the without talent but more
importantly preparation and uh and the
10 000 hour research reminds us that The
Closer you know you look at careers of
the gifted smaller the role
um is of innate Talent seems to play in
the bigger role preparation seems to
play and so that's really what uh what
amendment um 752 is is going after and
and I certainly think it's consistent
with the um uh with the intention that
um you know that we that we heard from
so many of us around the the
um you know the virtual table here uh
this morning thank you thank you very
much uh represent Leon you have your
hand up uh thank you Mr chair uh thank
you representative Leno for this
amendment I do agree that growth mindset
is important
um grittiness is important as well
Angela Duckworth has an amazing uh
amazing status
oh sorry you're not muted so Angela
Duckworth has an amazing amazing uh
study on Brit and the fact that it's not
it is that growth mindset also combined
with and with with reaching for
extraving striving for achievement the
10 000 hour role is very crucial but you
also can encounter somebody who either
has 10 000 hours where they are having
different hours and there are people
that have 10 000 hours where it's one
hour repeated hour after hour after hour
we do need to walk that line between
growth mindset but there's right now the
education landscape is moving away from
that idea of performance we're moving
away from that and we need to catch that
if we start losing sight of excellence
in New Hampshire I know we've rewarded
it a lot in the past but right now if
you look at the national stage we're
moving away from that looking not even
towards effort because right now they're
changing the grading system in my town
where you can't be penalized for not
turning in homework we need to make sure
or the student's effort is recognized
but we also need to make sure that
Excellence is recognized and I think
that simply replacing this with growth's
mindset loses a lot of a lot of what's
important about this I I do agree that
that these reports would hopefully
include efforts to encourage a growth
mindset and I think there's such a good
body of work uh both with what you've
referenced with Matt Gladwell what
you've referenced in the growth with
Carol dweck I do believe that that's in
the landscape we want to make sure we're
recognizing that and being able to read
the other school's notes will allow
these schools to get those best
practices and we can see how it's been
how we're reflecting things and how
we're doing it here in New Hampshire and
I think that that's going to help us
combine both that that striving for
excellence that
that inquisitiveness and the drive to
work work hard even when things go wrong
and to continue to push forward and not
just try and rest on some some label of
gifted but push forward and see what you
really can do with those gifts because
otherwise it's wasted you don't just
take a birthday present say thank you
and throw it out the door because you're
afraid you're going to break the toy you
go ahead and use it otherwise it's a
waste and we need to make sure that that
we're encouraging uh we're encouraging
these kids to challenge themselves to
fail and to fall forward instead of
instead of not pushing themselves
forward
growth and effort is near and dear to my
heart
it is probably the most important
aspect of every child's education
in this state
we should always
shouldn't always uh
I guess the emphasis
should always be on
growth
on how much effort is being put into
recognizing that
students grow and they should be growing
they may not all be proficient but they
grow and growth is probably the most
important aspect
at every grade level in school
are they moving forward
to me
that should be a whole different build
it should be a whole different
uh it's it's a concept that I would
support a hundred percent
the thing is I think that this bill oh
okay I keep eating this math
so the
the
process of identifying what schools do
for kids who are gifted and talented
is is a not um
a full
it's not a full reporting about everyone
there's just a certain certain kids that
just stand out that okay you know uh I
won't get into detail but I know what
some schools do and some schools don't
do what should do
but I think that your amendment is a is
an excellent bill
that's something that should be a
separate bill and I think it would fly
through and stop not one person would
disagree that growth and effort are
probably the most important part of an
education of a child and should be
identified
but I think this is a different thing
it's just something for that person that
is just a little bit above and beyond
everything that is being taught to that
child that this kid is just up there
and what are you doing for this kid
that's up there and how do you keep him
motivated or hurt
um that's why and I definitely am not
talking against your amendment I think
in regards to this bill
it's it's not applicable in my mind as
to what the the what the bill stands for
and and I certainly agree with you 100 I
love that you want to put that in for it
build the next turn I'll support it with
you but I I just don't think that that
uh reducing what we are thinking about
as gifted and talented I think we're
making too much of what gift and
talented it's a kid is going to stand
out
and are you doing anything for that kid
yeah we are in our school this is what
we do and uh so well and mentioned
which I know you know they have a great
program there but Manchester Central
does it Northwest Elementary doesn't you
know we
I don't know what they're doing
so that's that's the difference and and
I certainly uh I love that Amendment
save it for a bill
thank you thank you very much uh
represent like this you have your hand
up yeah I had a number of points
um with that and I absolutely agree with
with uh representative Shaw I was
wondering at first as if we could just
add the two together and have one
amendment that did both but then I'm not
sure this wouldn't be a non-germaine
Amendment so perhaps it is better to
have it as a separate bill I really like
this I think this is important
um I would hate for it to be lost but I
don't want to lose the gifted and
talented one as well there's talking
about two different things and the other
part with regard to the however many
hours I did listen to a sports a
medicine specialist who worked with
professionals and he said yes there is
an element of that but you can't just
have that you have to have that
underlying whatever and he was talking
about for athletes
um
for professional basketball players you
couldn't have a short person they just
weren't going to make it and almost all
basketball players their arms compared
to their height their arms are longer
than their height compared to everybody
else so so yeah you still have some
underlying something that then with the
5 000 hours or however many hours I
forget it was we'll make that person so
you need both you can't do it with just
one you need both and so this is helping
out the gifted one would be helping our
students who had the extra long arms or
the whatever that underlying thing is to
spend those 5 000 hours and reach that
potential but um so I'd like to see them
both go through and the other thing was
just a comment that somehow an awful lot
of people made made
references to the fact that having these
reports are worthless or won't go
anywhere or we'll just sit at the doe
and
they're not specific enough Etc and to
those people I would say this amendment
is the same way I didn't agree before
and I don't think it's so with this
amendment either I think either in
either case
filing the policies I mean filing the
the letters
the reports will be useful and I think
that just thinking about it will be
useful so
so I would say that this if you're going
to support this you should support the
other one as well
I have the chair yes go ahead thanks
very much Rick
um uh I I think what representative
Legas suggested
um makes a lot of sense I would support
that uh if we were somehow able to
combine these two into uh into a single
committee Amendment
um whether it's just sort of glomming on
one after the other or weaving them
together it doesn't matter
um uh to me but would the chair accept
that as a Germaine Amendment
it's a clerk well basically Germaine
Amendment you know I I couldn't do that
right now without taking a little time
and looking at this more thoroughly uh I
I just read the amendment over briefly
just not more than five to ten seconds
ago
um
I I think what we're trying to do here
is that we're going further than what
the initial intent of Representative
moffett's bill is and that's just to get
a better understanding what we're doing
as far as providing uh
support our programs our education for
our gifted and talented kids in the
state what what do we have out there
what are some of the practices that are
going on right now when we get that then
I think we're going to have to dig
deeper
um I've always been an advocate for
working with kids that are gifted and
talented and there's a lot of criteria
you can go into you know look at growth
and you can look at effort
um that's important uh obviously so a
lot of the kids which are counted
properly become Behavior phones and so
there's probably a correlation between
programs which have a
a best practice available for the
students or have a challenging courses
available in which they can sequel the
kid is bored they're not going to have
growth but that doesn't mean you don't
have a gifted kid here if you have a
gifted kid that's chosen to go the
opposite direction
so traditional programs have looked at
this and used a whole lot of different
criteria for identifying gifted
mentality specifically gifted leadership
skills achievement scores
IQ scores
recommendations of folks that they work
with and creativity I think that's a
very important one
um so uh I I at this point in time I
would say that the amendment is going to
go in a different direction they're
inclusive yes but I I don't think it
really the purpose the intent of the
bill was just not to try to uh
Define this thing at all we're just
trying to find out how the local
districts Define gifted or talented and
what programs they're offering I think
the next step uh Russia would be for you
to introduce your bill and probably get
down further in the weeds even and try
to identify we're going to go with
programs for these kids
and and that's uh are we going to do it
in the traditional mode are we going to
do it in more of a non-traditional mode
that you're in right now
um it's it's not just for those kids on
the right hand side of the bell curve
it's for you you can have kids that are
gifted in so many different ways that
are not identified to achievement uh so
at this point in time I'm not prepared
to say that it's not germane or it is
germane I just don't think it's
appropriate to be adding on to that
legislation I don't think it agrees with
the intent of what uh represent
moffett's trying to do
okay Mr chair last month so so you we've
been um we've been debating this for I
don't know I didn't see when we started
but let's just say it's been about an
hour or more
um and um and the way it looks you know
to me to the way it looks right now is
that um is that this bill uh uh would
probably pass I don't think it'll wind
up on the consent calendar and I think
they'll probably be a Minority Report in
a four fight
and um
and I I guess I'm I'm wondering and it
sounds like there may be support for a
um
um for an amendment that that unites
both of these
um Concepts and I think we're going to
be coming back on Thursday and for an
exact session and we could you know
introduce that
um uh hopefully not have not have to
have a protracted debate on it because I
think we've done that this morning and
have something and I don't want to I'm
not trying to get in front of
Representative Miler here but have
something that possibly goes on the
consent calendar
yeah
if I may uh Mr chair is it possible
to recess this until next Thursday and
in the in interim as we've done with
several other bills the interim to see
if there's a way with which we could
merge representative luno's uh concepts
with uh representative moffatt and have
the two of them get together to see if
there's a way that we might be able to
capture uh the uh the intent of both of
these uh proposals so that we could
place this on the consent calendar and
move it forward because this has been a
substantive conversation that we've just
had and I think uh it would be more
inclusive of being able to engage the
process so that we could be broader and
and to look at this because it I think
it would send a much broader message a
much more direct message about the need
to really address this across the board
could that happen
Mr chair I'm going to first have uh
representative respond
you sure thank you Mr chair uh and I
have to point out there is a motion
that's been seconded that's that's on
the on the floor uh I think
representative lunos thoughts uh a
striking chord with all of this and I
think that uh what he is looking at is
something that deserves more discussion
I don't think it deserves at this moment
and I do have to point out that uh the
the arguments that were expressed
earlier against the First Amendment uh
certainly all would apply against the
the Second Amendment I think that's
that's very interesting
um and I do want to also point out that
uh we have been talking about this for a
long time and uh that is actually the
beauty of the intent of the original
bill was simply to uh facilitate and
create a long overdue discussion on this
topic of an underserved population
uh and so I think in microcosm you're
seeing what will what if this bill is
amended moves forward happen all over
the state will be this very type of a
healthy discussion will happen in
healthy and overdue discussion will
happen uh Statewide
uh representative Mullen pointed out
what Bedford is doing I think that's
precisely uh what we would like to get
into this this best practices folder
because bedford's doing some things that
I think uh we should shine a light on
for other other schools to or districts
to consider so anyway there is a motion
on the floor I think that needs to be
addressed and then um we could go from
there I'll represented by Ford
thank you Mr chairman uh I was wondering
if maybe there are two issues here that
we need to separate and one I I took a
particular notice of the people who
spoke in terms of getting the Department
of Education to make a response and I
may be the simpler solution for that is
to Simply
modify uh the original motion to an
accrued a request of the Department of
Education from the legislature to give
us their analysis of this
and therefore that would invite them and
I don't see how they could politely
refuse us to make an analysis of what
we're introducing here and then follow
along simultaneously or subsequently
with an analysis of the sort that
representative luno has suggested which
has a great deal of Merit
so I'm just trying to look to sort of
through the how to work our way through
the weeds here
that that's what I'm raising this
question for I think there have been a
wonderful number of of just points of
view on this and it's been very
enlightening
has previously been done uh we you don't
have to amend the motion to uh achieve
what you're trying to address it can't
be done through an administrative uh uh
request from this committee to the
Department of Education to uh you know
let's let's delve into this issue Let's
uh have some information provided by you
um we've done that before I can remember
doing that with representative guy or
several years ago and we we did some uh
uh issue addressed issues such as this
uh without having to do it even with a
bill we we did it uh just as an
administrative request from this
committee to the department to get down
to and find some answers to various
topics I think we can do that but what
I'd like to do before I go any further
than this there's a couple people with
hands up here where I'm saying Leon do
you have a question
um I have a point Mr chair if I may make
it I think that the growth mindset is is
a very important uh issue too but if we
have them together sort of in a joint
question that's going to make it harder
for it's going to make it easy for
districts or schools to only focus where
they are at a strong if we're already
strong on encouraging a growth mindset
that's what they'll address and then say
that the growth mindset helps the gift
of students if they're already strong
enough strong on gifted students but
they aren't encouraging that growth
mindset they may do the same thing where
they point out those programs and gloss
over the the growth mindset I think that
these should come forth in separate
years because I think this is a
wonderful absolutely wonderful idea
representative luno but I think that if
Leslie's come forward separately it's
going to be too easy for them to get
Blended together and we're going to lose
we're going to lose the benefit that
both of these can break
yeah just uh
first part of the amendment sounds good
as everybody can sing but
read the next part of the amendment
completely replaces the bill
I just want to make that clear it
replaces
that completely replaces 20 ads New
189.29 B which is replaces
so I just want to make that clear so I
will be against
it thank you
uh represent luno thanks very much Mr
chair representative Bloom is is correct
the amendment does replace the um uh the
bill and um and I think representative
Leon's Point
um is um is also uh uh on spot and um uh
but I think could be accomplished with a
um with a with a committee amendment
that um that tackles these two uh issues
as separate points a b
29-b and 29 I'm assuming there's no 29-c
um so um so this part could be um could
be brought in as 29c and require
districts to uh to report out on both
um uh I think I I agree I think they are
related
um you know in terms of making sure that
school districts are challenging uh
students and um and and you know
collectively we should be able to get a
um the the department I'm sorry should
be able to uh to get a um a rich Trove
of um of practice data from uh from
school districts across the state so
again I think a um uh a
you know a
an amendment a committee amendment that
doesn't blend the two but has the two
um in series uh as 29b uh for um for
um gifted and talented and 29c for
encouragement of growth and effort I
think is very consistent and um and and
I think is it would be a good outcome
from the the investment of time and
discussion that this committee has put
in this morning
okay uh are there any other uh concerns
questions uh from the committee
okay what I'm going to do is I'm going
to call a brief caucus so I can talk
with uh folks I have here who are about
15 minutes I came in unfortunately you
know halfway through this thing and so
I'd like to get a better understanding
of it myself so uh 15 minutes we'll come
back at 11 30. does he have to do the
recess we have a motion there's a motion
on the floor you can call a clock
you're not calling it caucus okay that
was just a question Mel are we doing the
same thing
I couldn't hear you Mel
looks like we're we're doing the same
thing
I'm going to disconnect from here
uh
foreign
quite quiet yeah what happened to that
okay we're about ready to start here
not your first time yes
[Music]
it's called over you can overthink
realized I never took my medicine
foreign
meds right here for those because
sometimes
okay I hope so it is 11 30 I think we
need net over here
is everybody in place here and
um
here now
okay for that
we've got uh
who has
no not mine that's bad
okay can people hear us out there now
yep
okay we do have a motion on the table
and I've made the decision and I am
making the decision now that we're just
going to go ahead and let the decision
be made by the full committee through
voting on the motion that we have on the
table that gets loaded up that's where
we are if it gets voted down that's all
we are and then we can proceed
accordingly
so with that if there's any more
discussion on this bill 321
yes representative
I think we're on the amendment sorry
sorry
yeah
so we're on the amendment right now
and this uh
0752h further description yeah I think
representative Mullen had a comment she
wanted to make yes sir okay represent
yes I see you thank you Mr chair I I
just wanted to reference back to this
concept that uh if we were in fact to
adopt representative luno's uh Amendment
either on its own or in a joint
Amendment with representative moffatt
that somehow or another it was going to
be
creating all of this cumbersome
additional work uh and we have we
continued our robust discussion you'll
be surprised right into our caucus where
um I I shared with members that the way
that I read this the growth and effort
aspect of this amendment is meant to
measure the growth and effort aspects of
gifted and talented students not the
entire School body
so
um representative Sean I uh had some
clarifying conversation about the idea
that if you're in a school district like
like bedford's that has a gifted and
talented program and you're asked to
report out on uh some specifics of what
you do for growth and effort with your
gifted and talented students that it's
probably going to take about 15 minutes
to write up a summary statement of goal
setting of uh
compacting curriculum of setting up
independent study with students I I
don't think that it is nearly as
cumbersome as people fear that it might
be because it only applies to 189 colon
29 which is identification and
accommodation of gifted students not the
entire student body
are there further comments on on the
bill right now on on the amended
is it an order
uh to have a motion come forward to
recess this until Thursday to allow uh
representative Moffat and representative
luno together to see if they might be
able to Cobble together a uh an
amendment that would uh basically
Encompass the conversations that we've
had around this today is that an order a
motion to recess until Thursday
we have a motion on the table right now
I could resist but I'm not going to do
that
um I I feel that there's we need to just
vote on this amendment now if in fact
the committee believes this is a topic
it's evidently uh generated a lot of
discussion here uh positive constructive
discussion I'm I'm glad we're seeing us
starting to address student growth and
effort and and I'd like to see that uh
done not just for gifted kids either I'd
like to see it for all our kids and I
think this is a area where commissioner
edible is also stressed remember we used
to measure the the outcomes
of our adequate education and the
delivery of an ad good education through
strictly and the performance side on
achievement only
now we're looking at achievement and
growth which is very important
if there's growth going on that's
exactly what we want to see as long as
we don't keep dropping the bar down and
that's our proficiency level is going
down but we do want to see growth I
think that this is a topic which
deserves further discussion but in an
activity and we could develop a
subcommittee just to work at that a work
group to work on this and work with the
Department
to to try to get to that end that
outcome that reptile oil is looking for
so uh if if this amendment gets voted
down I I'm prepared to you know work
towards the the desired end that
represents Bruno and others I hear are
interested in looking at I I also agree
we need to be looking at growth
um
and effort
is is a motion to retain at this point
in time in order not with another motion
on the table we have a motion on the
table right now on this particular a uh
Amendment now the the emotion to retain
does not take precedent
not
you can't have retention on a specific
Amendment
you can retain a bill but that Amendment
right now
um is
you've got to get the the
so the so the if I make this clarify
here so once we dispose of this
particular Amendment
and we're then back to the main motion
as OTP as amended at that point in time
is it a is it appropriate to move to
retain
I I'd have to check and see if the
motion to retain because you will have a
motion on the table which will be ought
to pass as amended right that will be on
the table so there will be a motion put
forward now if you vote down that
ought to pass as amended then we can
have a motion for retention
go back two steps to get to that right
we have to take a couple steps before we
even get to that where I'm going to
accept a motion before we can thank you
thank you for that clarification you're
welcome so with that uh we're going to
move forward here and I'm going to ask
on this amendment 0752h that represents
Shaw would you please call the rules yes
representative cordelli
um
yes it's the second amendment yes
oh
representative ball no
representative l or
reluctantly no
represent like this unfortunately no
representative
yeah I love it I'm sorry
uh no
person no
representative address no
representative board no
represented lay on no understand sodi do
you know Christina Miler yes
yes yes
that scanner
yes
representative Allison yes
yes you're that way yes
yes
thank you very much uh representative
I'd like to move multi-pays amended
for HP 321
yes for hb321
is there a second representation yes
so we have a motion on the table now
octopass on 321 as amended
uh made by representative Muppets second
by representative Shaw represent Moffett
do you have anything to further
discussion I think we've talked for two
hours on this and uh a vocal vote
represent Shaw
no I just think that if we did have a
conversation or able to combine
the two together knowing now that that
is referring only to gifted and talented
and not the whole entire school because
I I didn't get a chance to really in uh
indulge into the
um into the amendment I I think I could
have supported as an AV but
um as a a Spanish
um as a stand-alone I would go with the
other cast as amended right now
thank you
yeah point of inquiry of the chair so um
so I don't think this is a new motion by
representative Moffett I think this is
going back to the original motion of OTP
you know with the with the amendment so
we're winding unwinding the Motions so
um so this is not a new motion and and
would it be in order though if this
motion were to fail that
either a motion to retain or a um a
request to recess would be in order so
that um so that another amendment could
um could be produced and uh and uh
exactly along the lines as to what
representative Shaw was saying
um where where the um the Moffett
Amendment would be 29b and the the luno
um Ellison Woodcock Amendment would be
29c
um no change of wording uh and that that
could be brought up on the committee on
Thursday
okay we're gonna move forward now yes
it was a pi yeah okay that's right
that's a parliamentary inquiry yeah yeah
uh I will explain that we'll we'll
follow that we'll have this vote and
then we'll respond to you following the
vote depending upon what the outcome is
so with that let's go ahead and have the
vote Madam clerk would you please call
the roll
difficult choices
um representative Port Ali yes is ought
to pass as amended with Amendment 0537h
representative yes
representative Allard yes
yes
representative yes representative Andrus
yes representative yes
no
no no
yes
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no
representative Allison oh
representative Mullen no
representative way
no
all day passes
uh representative black yes
boxing okay
so taking it at the discussion we just
we just had obviously there is uh
information that we've just been going
over that deserves further inquiry on
the part of this committee so that this
topic will be brought up at a
uh by us and I will when we have a
little bit more time we're trying to
accept all these bills right now but
upon getting this done
uh we can have a committee as a whole
and look at it and from that committee
as a whole we can design an
administrative letter signed by this
committee as we did years ago when we
sent one to commissioner Berry asking
for information and uh to delve into the
issue here of encouraging student growth
and effort so we will pursue that once
we get all these bills exact and also
we're starting to get targeted with
Senate bills as well so but it's on the
docket and we won't forget it
okay representative Luna will file a
Minority Report
thank you very much
and the majority reporters
so we're going to try to get one more
Bill done before lunchtime here HP 71.
and with that I I'd love to represent
phone for a motion please I like to make
a motion off the pass and and that and
recommend Amendment 0498h0498h
okay and it was second by represent
Allard uh made by reps and boom on HB 71
that's a bill that deals with emergency
uh meetings
and he's also indicated that he has an
amendment that uh please I'd like to go
ahead and discuss as well so uh
represent phone
but thank you uh Mr chair on the
amendment on the discussion we had at
the original hearing there was a lot of
concern about
other things that can happen you know
which could have been covered by
Insurance anyway but the amendment just
specifies the court shall not allow
special meeting if the emergency
involves a collective bargaining women
so all the other stuff was taken out so
it just caused by collective bargaining
agreement and to that you know it's
still no means no if the school district
at their meeting whether that the
regular the school district meeting and
the people vote no on collective
bargaining agreement
the court cannot give a special
emergency meeting for that it has to go
to the following year so everything else
is taken out so anyway that's with the
amendment do you have do you have the
number of your Amendment represents on
0498h do we did we get you in there yes
I don't have it I don't have a copy of
that I don't either
thank you and everybody who had a copy
of it
it's a long time ago I knew on March 3rd
find it
yes Mr chair just a question of the
sponsor yes yes go ahead so so um so
thanks representative boam for bringing
this forward would would this prevent a
school district from having a subsequent
question on the warrant that that says
something along like like we've seen
before that says something along the
lines of if the um collective bargaining
agreement in the prior question fails uh
does this body authorize a special
meeting to be held to consider no that's
what could happen I mean they can put
that actually in the warrant saying if
this warrant fails we can have a special
meeting right so so so this amendment
would not bar that from happening well
just pause the judge for somebody
requesting an emergency special meeting
gotcha
doing a special needs it can be done
beforehand like you had said
in other words if it's in the warrant
saying a special meeting could be right
that's right
just just pause a court hearing for a
judge to rule or
yeah I'm looking for your amenity or you
said March 3rd yeah
well it was made on February 24th and
was sent that month to third we just got
it Again Jennifer Ford just sent it out
to everybody okay hey thank you Jennifer
thank you
do you guys need hard copies
no no I'm just trying to get here I see
it on top of that I distributed also
Julie I don't have it
just came in
because everybody had a that it's it
says basically a one-liner yes
the court shall not allow a special
meeting if the emergency involves a
collective bargaining agreement that was
voted down at the regular meeting
including a collective bargaining
agreement modified after the regular
meeting
so
so this is open for discussion at this
point in time
reps at home if there's anybody who has
a you can answer some of those questions
yeah
appreciate the chance
either to you or to representative uh
boam it doesn't matter because I just
want to make sure I'm clear on the line
six is I just printed the amendment
thank you John by the way on the lines
six and seven of the amendment where it
says including a collective buying
agreement modified after the regular
meeting
so is the intent here representative
that if the committee if the
negotiations get together and they agree
following that nothing can happen they
can't go they can't move it forward
it will move forward that the next
meeting
not the quartet rule of the special
meeting I mean that's the same thing if
they
put in the warrant initially saying and
we can have a special meeting after them
that's no problem they will do
modifications that will do it but just
at a court hearing a judge can't rule oh
yeah we can have a special meeting now
even though you made the modifications
which if you remember my testimony would
and others that the problem was the
special meeting might not even happen
until September October which delays the
tax bill and people don't get the tax
billed right before Christmas instead of
the end so that's the main issue on this
for a special meeting thank you
a question
yes I do
um so uh when a court hears a petition
for an emergency uh meeting they right
now in statute they're given uh five
guidelines to follow
um
the severity of the harm to be avoided
the urgency of the petitioner's need
whether the claim claimed emergency was
foreseeable or avoidable whether the
appropriation could have been made at
the annual meeting
and whether there are alternative
remedies not requiring an appropriate
appropriation
you wanna I I am wondering if you want
to add a sixth uh guideline there for
the court that if it's a collective
bargaining agreement uh it's got to be
refused
that you're taking the
um
you're taking the hand away from the
judge and saying if it's collective
bargaining that's it it can't it can't
even be going to an emergency meeting
regarding it meets these other five
criteria the part of that law said the
judge will consider the following and
um and whether or not it was done if if
for example if it was on a warrant you
shall consider if not if it's it's a
real emergency that wasn't voted on
at the district meeting there's no
problem if it was voted on
at the at the regular school district
meeting collect the bargaining agreement
was voted on then he can't
because it was voted so a follow-up uh
Mr chair
so so they um what you're saying is I
and I I'm trying to sort it out you're
saying that
the court that that you can the court
can't even consider it they they can't
even follow they're not guidelines or
anything this is a blanket statement
Court you can't even consider this
appeal if it involves collective
bargaining is that right right because
it was already voted on by the people
well the other ones are voted on the
appeals for this emergency is also for
other warn articles so if if somebody
had a Warren article for
um a school repair and it was voted down
uh they wanted to repair their boiler uh
but it wasn't wasn't at critical mass
and then halfway through the school year
the boiler blew up
uh
they they couldn't because it had been
voted down as a warrant article they
couldn't appeal it to the court to have
an emergency hearing and what I
understand is this amendment says yes
they can
they can do any of those except
collective bargaining is that correct
right because collective bargaining
isn't really an emergency the people
said no and that and no means no in the
case of a boiler like you mentioned in
another case that was brought up the
schools should have insurance on that
anyway but yes the judge can consider
this was happened in 1998 as we put in
because there was a lot of special
meetings and this bill law was made then
because it sort of limit that limited
the judge but I can't see and other
people can't see is why just because
people said no the reflective bargaining
agreement that could result in an
emergency it is not an emergency and in
most cases like I've lived in Litchfield
one 44 and a half years we've had a lot
of contracts go down and the following
year the modifications were made and
voted on again and in most cases I don't
know any that didn't all the cases
resolved have been retroactive pay
increases for the previous year so
nobody lost anything except the year
getting that pay raise but the point was
it the changes needed to be made the
public said no we need to make these
changes and this happened what happened
in Litchfield the changes were a result
of the people did not like the health
insurance part of it so
yes this takes takes
takes what we thought was in law to
start with that they couldn't have one
because like somebody imagined was only
two in the last six years or something
like that but yeah I mean in some cases
we know you farm for judges and one
that'll give you what you want so in
this case it just takes the hand out of
Judges which we've done in the past
where a lot of other laws so no you
can't do it go through a collective
bargaining that's it
further discussion
for me
is represent Myler
oh there it is
yeah I I would
yes am I am I recognized yes okay thank
you Mr chair yeah I'm going to vote I'm
going to vote against this because it
basically takes a discretion away from
the uh from a local school board that
wants to move on a particular item that
they think is important and to tie their
hands on this I think is is not uh
relevant notwithstanding uh
representative Baum's comment about
retroactivity Etc it's just another
example of trying to take the discretion
of the local school board away from uh
just their decision making on how they
think the school district should be run
further further questions
one question
um if you have an emergency meeting
I know we had an emergency meeting in
Woodsville when we're looking at
approving monies for the new school
building project which we did but in
order to have that measured passed we
had about a two-thirds a majority not
just a simple uh majority
what's the case of emergency meeting
such as this is that it had to be passed
by a just a simple majority or or is
there a two-thirds ruling or any sixty
percent
I I'm not unfamiliar so I just know
questions
anybody have an answer I don't have an
answer to that
no that the bond issue two-thirds there
was 60 percent of the mind has passed
for a bondage
when you're talking about appropriating
additional dollars
but this this could means if
some issue has been raised for other
things I like good stuff
something happened uh under school and
it didn't foresee it
okay then you can have a special meeting
for something that wasn't foreseen in
this case it was it was foreseen we
needed to deflect the body the
negotiations were done but the people
said no yes the school board should be
prevented by the people the people vote
for the school board the school board
should be
uh going with the people that voted for
him because the problem is with
collective bargaining agreements with
both sides the school board because I've
been on a few of them school board and
the teachers negotiating agree on
something then they both have to still
say they agree on it so at that point
yes that they if one side wants it the
other side so the
yeah even though they may not want to
but the point is yeah this ties their
hand because the people said no
unforeseen emergencies and they'll
Collective bargain agreement is not
enough for a scene of Americans
any further discussion
from committee members
not seeing any math work
what's the motion what's our emotion put
forth motion before the amendment 0498h
this isn't a podcast on
zero four nine eight H right
representative yes
yes
that valid yes
instead of like it yes
rather than a mop it yes
yes
representative board yes
Audi yes
representative Myler no
I will know no
right there Sean no
representative Cornell no
represent Tanner no
representative Ellison oh
representative Mullen no
representative way
I vote no and I declare my intent to
participate in this discussion on the
basis that
um this merely changes uh the discretion
of the courts it has no direct impact
upon any of the organizations that I am
a member of thank you
representative lab yes
[Music]
the Motions for all the past has been
mended on HB 71
yay we have emotions to pass HB 71 as
amended
uh to pass
um second by representative Allard
further discussion
okay
I passed as amended
um
representative cordelli yes
HP 71.
uh representative balm yes
representative Allard yes representative
yes representative yes representative
Hopson yes representative Andrus yes
representative Ford yes
yes representative yes
Senator miler
uh no
no Representative no
where's their shot no
representative Cornell no
or is that a planner no
representative Ellison oh
okay no
nope
no
because then what yes
was it being a minority vote uh yes uh
representative Tanner will submit that
report
thank you
and uh representative yes it's on the
way to you for the subject is right
thank you
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take a break here at our lunch uh so
we'll pick it up a quarter of one
order one thank you you're welcome
not being here for some of those
business across in and out from the
Senate
and
so no is he talking I thought they were
talking you want me to run back
representative Ladd I'm sorry are you
still speaking to the committee
I thought that you had closed it I muted
the room that's completely my mistake if
you're still still addressing the
committee
I thought you had moved on
hey Jen yes can you hear me I don't know
if representative Ladd can hear Do we
have any heads up of what's coming up
this afternoon I'm sure he was going
there but I I had I heard his voice
reduce in volume and I thought that we
had gone on to lunch and it's completely
by mistake I'm so sorry
no if
no that's all right can you unmute Rick
though or yes they are unmuting the room
right now oh okay are you gonna hear me
out there I I want to look at the list
of the bills we haven't done yet and I'm
gonna need about five ten minutes here
to try and get that squared away good
Rick Rick I think
yeah we can we can set that order out
that'll be great right excellent good
thank you Rick all right we'll see we'll
catch you everybody in a little bit okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
er uh
earlier in our lunch break the first of
those bills
is HP 464 that's the commission school
funding bill and there is an amendment
there for the work that's been cut
forward by myself and representative so
I'd like to start off with 464.
can everybody hear us out there
yes
I got that the thumbs up
[Music]
uh representative Ladd uh Rick uh uh
David's not on yet well he's not here
yet no
hey maybe what I'll do is I'll jump over
them
yeah I've seen this as a joint uh
Amendment
myself I'll jump now to the next
building we're going to do that's uh
458.
let's go to 458.
foreign
yes I would like to move
um
OTP
for 458 made by professional life like
us and uh reps and hops are you making a
second yes thank you very much
representative if you have any
discussion on your emotions yeah
um
well I agree that schools
um I need to look at and help women who
do not and cannot afford
um Master hygiene products
the bill that was passed last year and
passed into law was a late 28th a
violation
and I believe it needs to be
taken out and leave it up to the school
districts people say well school
districts provide toilet paper well
there's no mandate the school districts
provide toilet paper they choose to
provide toilet paper and they can choose
to provide menstrual hygiene products as
well
but for us to mandate either one of
those would be it is a 28-a violation
and we have no business mandating that
cool thank you thank you very much reps
and hops do you have any comments nope I
I see represent Allison you have your
hand up art uh yes thank you very much
Mr chairman uh comments on this
particular bill this is the most
punitive legislation that I've seen come
before the committee in the last two and
a half years that I've been involved
with this uh
we have if in fact the bill is approved
and we go back to where we were three
years ago we will have some school
districts that will be able to provide
these products and we'll have some who
cannot or will not we will be in a
position at that point
and of
young women going to the school nurse in
the first year of this new bill and
saying
what happened to the machines that were
in the in the ladies room or wherever
they were uh because I'm having my
period And I need some product and the
answer at the school nurse will have to
give under that set of circumstances is
this is uh an unpended mandate so you
don't get any more now because it's an
unfunded mandate
uh if my daughter was still at Concord
High School
uh at this point she would be testifying
against this bill in a much more
eloquent way than her father is doing uh
I strenuously objected this bill and I
would be voting against it
very much represent Ellison uh represent
Leon uh thank you Mr chair as I probably
could speak uh most directly to this of
everybody on the committee given that I
have a one-year-old this is an issue
that women and others who menstruate
will be facing for decades this the
schools provide a safe place in order to
learn lessons some of those are
the planning ahead that when you may be
encountering this monthly event to have
it in mind and also know what you're
going to do if you are caught unaware
School School nurses will have them they
will be available they have been
available it's just a matter of where
and when and this is something where
where girls and others will be able to
go to the nurse and access these
materials but that small amount of
thinking to make sure that they can
think ahead say oh it feels like this
may be happening I'm going to go ahead
and take the proactive step we'll save
them from having a significant problem
on the job or out at a store or
somewhere else in the world where we
don't mandate the free availability of
these products there are stop Gap
measures there's things that can be done
but I think that where we
have an unfunded mandate and there's
also the issue that we're not preparing
them for the real world I know that
there is compassion these are available
in the school nurses and this does not
need to be legislated to the point it is
we need to get this back out of the law
uh representative Tanner
are you on mute
Linda we can't hear you Linda
no can't hear you
can't can't hear a word there Linda
now we can Linda we can't hear you now
you can okay yeah
um thank you
um
as you know I taught many years and I
was the phys ed teacher so
um oftentimes I had extra pads and and
and tampons on hand for students that
that uh really
um and in adolescence uh periods can be
very unpredictable and can be very
lighter extremely heavy uh and for a
young woman uh just starting in those
Cycles um it isn't like it's every 28
days it isn't like it's the same thing
all the time it's it's really hard for
them so that's one thing the second
thing is that it's kind of like shaming
it's uh like um
with our we've talked about the the
lunch program I guess that would be one
of the examples I'd kind of use uh for a
student to have to go to the nurse's
office or even to come to the phys ed
teacher and ask for uh a pad or a tampon
um for
some students it's no big deal
but for a lot of students and
particularly students that can't afford
it
it is a huge huge deal
and just to point out to you how huge
and how misunderstood this whole thing
is from an adult's point of view and
particularly from a male adult's point
of view is that for you for a couple of
years the Jan a new janitor came on and
he kept complaining that the that the
toilet in the girls locker room was
always getting plugged and he just he
couldn't understand why young women just
didn't understand that they weren't
supposed to flush these products down
the down the toilet and I said to him on
numerous occasions the reason that
you're getting this is because they
don't want to walk across from the stall
over to the wastebasket to dispose of
the of the product and if you were to
put the containers for them to put that
away in between the Stalls so that they
didn't have to leave the stall visibly
to do that
you wouldn't get the toilets backed up
well it took a a few months of
convincing he did it and you know what
happened the toilets didn't plug up and
it seems like such a small thing but
that's how self-conscious young women
and girls are about their periods and
and
um so this bill
um and the people that even at first in
schools were like you know this is this
is a problem this is going to be
terrible you know
now we're seeing the benefits we know
that that girls and young women stay
home they stay home they miss school
um and they do it because they don't
have the proper products we know that
well if you're a woman you know that
there are times when you least expect it
and all of a sudden something fails on
you and and it is it is embarrassing
even as an adult sometimes to do that to
to actually have to come up with
something so
um I can't believe how
um
this bill is uh just just dismissive of
young girls and and young women who who
really need this uh this support and I
uh can't believe that
28a applies to a situation where the
school's already buying paper towels
toilet paper
um they're buying uh hand sanitizer
machines
all kinds of things around uh personal
hygiene and this is a small addition to
it I don't think it qualifies for 28a at
all so I'm going to be voting against
this bill thank you very much
representative like this yes
um the big expense in this
uh was the machines and those have
already been purchased I can't see a
school taking them down just because we
said it's not mandated anymore
this
um
it's it it's not saying don't do this
you can't do this just because we're
taking this
repealing this 28-day violation bill it
doesn't say stop doing it it says make
your own decision on doing it
um just like we make our own decision on
toilet paper and paper towels and all
those other things every school district
makes their own decision and yes most of
them provide it now schools are in the
habit of providing it now they've
already bought the machines
so now it's not as big of a deal but
they should be the ones who say yes this
is what we're going to do yes we'll put
it in our school operating budget yes we
will do it not us mandating it when
we're not providing the funds for it so
it is a 28-day violation we should not
be doing that we should leave it up to
the school districts
it's also our responsibility and we
spend a long time last
term making it clear that yes women do
need this and if you recall any of you
who were here I I spoke on this
from the floor and I started out with
the story of how women needed this and
how they weren't coming I'm not there's
no argument about that but I ended with
but it's a 28-a violation we can do this
we can volunteer to supply things the
schools can look for things they can get
they can get um charitable donations of
supplies they can take collections and
have a collection box where people can
drop them off and then they can be put
in the machines whatever but we
shouldn't be mandating it and that's
that's it thank you very much
representative
thank you representative Vlad
um and I do have to speak in this I know
it's going to be similar to uh
276 afterwards so I'm hoping we get this
all done at once
um
I I do this does bother me this bill
this this uh
OTP and I'll tell you why uh first off
not the least of that the governor took
major photo ops press releases and said
this final levels of seal for women last
June when he sat there stood there with
Colleen if you recall the young lady who
brought this bill to the committee
um that's the first thing the second
thing I find kind of ironic this and uh
National Women's months here that that
we bring this bill up but beyond that
uh having been in high school settings
in Middle School settings and coached uh
it follows me I'll tell you why
take an average uh adolescent young lady
who has heavy flow three days of just
three days a month
so three days a month
times 10 months is 30 school days now
that's not a month that's actually six
weeks of school time
when the youngsters do not come to
school if they don't have sufficient
products it's not a case where they can
plan for it it's the case they can't
afford it and that's why they don't come
so if you look at it from grades 7
through 12 that's 180 days of times
those youngsters do not come to school
well it doesn't seem to me like that's a
very good investment for the teacher a
teacher would get 15 days off a year for
sick leave but not 30. most people in
employment in an industry get what one
one and a half days a month not 30 but
this is not a sick piece
um school is like work we tell the
students this is work it's your job to
come to school be prepared
well we this is their work and we tell
The Adolescents the same thing so if you
go back to that number that number of of
30 days a year
um even at five bucks a pop we're
talking three hundred dollars well let's
see over the course of six years
and what's the average tax bill and some
in some schools for uh per person around
12 or 13 14 000 the middle average rate
was 69 and then some schools like
Moulton Borough 32 000 well they
probably don't have that problem but we
look at those those range of school
districts uh like a key like like a
Manchester like uh Conway you take that
so that student has lost a whole year of
schooling from seven to twelve and for
saving 500 bucks versus wasting
seventeen thousand dollars
um that's that's a huge that's a huge
loss of wasted investment not to mention
particularly in the younger grades when
the student comes back to school
she had if she missed a key a key
concept or a key lesson that has to be
re-taught that's another problem um so
that bothers me but the the reality is
that
these young kids
are at the bottom of the social economic
class
this is a case of The Haves and the
have-nots this is basically a case of
discrimination where we klept the class
we wonder why we wonder why when you
look at all your statistics on academic
achievement the social ultimate class at
the bottom typically has the most
difficult time well it's more difficult
if they're not there so that that that's
a concern to me candidly
um and that's exactly where that term
period poverty came from
that these people these youngsters these
women adolescents are in poverty now
some of you are on this table even the
men with the white shirts and ties on
may have got a phone call somewhere
along the line if you had a a daughter
and said geez can you come to school and
bring Sally a change of clothes because
she had an accident
and you say oh yeah we'll rushed right
up or can you just take her home because
she had an accident well that doesn't
that's just my dog agreeing that that
doesn't that doesn't happen when you
call a single parent who's in a lower uh
so economic heat class who's working on
a part-time job I can't come to school I
can't leave my job I don't have a spare
Feast we had enough money to stop well
you wouldn't be there so that young lady
sits in the nurse's office or assists in
the assistant principal's office so
those things are kind of concerning to
me
um it just makes it it does make me
awesome and I will look at the 28a piece
I understand the you know it's a 28a 28a
but we do have the one case one case of
the City versus the city of Concord
versus the state
in that case the Court ruled the New
Hampshire Supreme Court ruled
we're a local subdivision in this case
had a responsibility for the subject
Matter's case so some change in the
scope of responsibility including an
increase in financial responsibility
does not result in a 28a violation so I
would suggest to you that if we are if
you really want to go out in that Limb
and use 28a if we are using that concept
then the schools already provide as some
folks have said some uh products for the
nurse's office some product perhaps for
the physi teacher so they REI providing
it so if you look at if you look at the
the intention of city of Concord versus
the state the new the New Hampshire
Supreme Court ruled that when you expand
that it's not a 28a violation in that
case
uh so I'll leave you with one story and
one comment the story was when I said
this on the floor of the house last year
this is my first a few years ago my
first well speak
um that's why it really bothers me
when I was coaching
I had a softball team of young women
only 10 kids they weren't very good
probably couldn't be coached better
um but we we're doing okay and we go to
our first home game
and I look in the field warming up and I
said to the girls but where's someone so
I where's that shot stop and they said
well coach she hasn't come to school
today I said why not she says because
all we have is white uniforms it's her
time of the month she never comes to
school during her time of the month I
mean this is just a it's not like an
unusual thing this is these kids know
this I mean there's a clear stigma for
girls if we look at adolescent young
women and they're supposed to be
building confidence and building their
identity and we do this we say oh no but
stay home or just uh we don't have any
help we can help you and I'll leave you
with a couple comments I heard to her
this morning
one was from representative Moffett this
is a chance to serve in underserved
population that's exactly what it is and
I would also suggest you every time we
hear the good representative from
moultonborough speak when he gets
emotional about something that's passion
to him he'll say to us well what about
the human cost what about the cost of
kids for crying out loud and that's
exactly what he says and this is the
cost of the kids what about the cost of
the kids for crying out loud
uh thank you Mr chair uh representative
Woodcock brings up a couple of good
points some of these young girls with
very very happy
probably need to make sure that there's
not actually an underlying issue uh
beyond that once they've been checked
out and they know that this isn't
actually a health problem they're not
going to be well served by the same same
products would be available for
everybody in the bathroom I'm sure I'm
sure that the gentleman Representatives
here don't really know the difference
between the the different products on
the market but if you had the products
that would help these young girls with
very heavy flows in the bathrooms you'd
be putting other girls Health at risk
for tops of shop syndrome if you were
offering that level of protection in the
tampon this is an area where if you have
that individualized product available in
the nurse's office you can figure out
what you need and by being able to go to
the nurse you can get whatever high
intensity products you need I know that
this is being met this was a way that it
was trying to address a problem
away this is a matter of making sure
that if the basket runs out nobody gets
in trouble just making sure that this
goes back to a common sense issue and we
also want to make sure that these girls
can feel comfortable going to the
nurse's office and they don't have to
wear something the color of my my dress
today in order to feel comfortable those
days just because what's provided in the
bathroom is inadequate for their needs
thank you thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman um
I'll confess right away that I have
absolutely no
expertise in this subject
beyond the question of it being a 20
minute a day issue
and if this is an important issue for us
as a policy plot
then we need to be paid
and simple we need to write that check
to the school districts and I
admitted I come from a small visitor
but in doing the research on this bill
in my district
based on the last bill that we passed
two years ago my district opted not to
purchase any Machinery uh for this
instead they dispatch periodically a
School employee to the local food bank
where they have made a under the table
deal with the food bank to take products
from the food bank and send it to the
school which is a dubious
uh a dubious connection at best
um again I go back to if this is
important
we need to fund it
we heard some examples and the word like
180 dollars to one of the large District
well of course in my district it's
nothing akin to them but the four
thousand dollars in my district was a
deal breaker in the school bud
it's it's not a matter of
not wanting these young women to have
what they need it's a matter of paying
for it and if we're going to take a
stand
and say it's important then we need to
make it important with our checkbook
thank you very much uh representative uh
thank you Mr chairman
um I find this to be an embarrassment
um to to remove this requirement uh to
act as if it will have no impact
whatsoever
um is a complete embarrassment
um it ignores the fact that there are
many students who cannot afford these
products
um it ignores the impact that rep my
colleague representative Woodcock
mentioned in terms of uh repeated
absences you know we already have in
statute the requirement that an employer
shall maintain reasonable and proper
toilet facilities and sent reasonable
sanitary and hygienic conditions for
employees so we have that in law for
employers and employees but we're not
going to have that in law for students
I mean I just find that amazing and I'm
going to be happy to go back to my
constituents and remind them that my
colleagues here now believe uh that the
provision of toilet paper is no longer a
necessity or required whatsoever uh and
that the school district can save money
by eliminating that as well so I'll be
voting against this Bill thank you
yes I just want to address various of
the issues made
representative Woodcock that was a
wonderful argument as to why we need to
provide these every district has
Representatives every district has
Representatives who care about this so I
would love to see you go to your school
district and convince them with those
wonderful arguments that you had about
why your school district should make
sure and provide these things
um that they should decide to do that
and provide them
and there are there are numerous
um companies who will provide these you
can make arrangements and some of the
school districts have made arrangements
to get supplies from them for free or
for very inexpensive for very little
money
um specifically because it's good
advertising for these products because
if girls use these this particular brand
in school when they become adults and
start buying their own
they will follow through with what they
used there in the school
um some girls do not go to school during
their period and it has nothing to do
with having or not having products it
may have to do with extreme cramps Etc I
certainly Miss days
because of that even though I had
products and the other thing is white
uniforms I know plenty of girls who have
problems with that
during that time of month even if they
have products because they don't always
stay contained I have certainly had to
get clothing from the nurse's office
even though I had a product
um because accidents happen sometimes
you overflow that's you know there are
all these issues are things that women
deal with
and girls deal with and I was a very shy
person I certainly did not want to go to
the nurse fortunately one of my friends
volunteered to walk with me because I
was hopelessly embarrassed
um but I still see
I I'm not saying we don't need this I'm
not saying and I did not say we should
not supply toilet paper I'm saying that
schools do Supply toilet paper on their
own decision and so they can supply this
on their own decision and if we think a
school should do that we all have the
ability to go to our school and convince
them with wonderful arguments like like
uh representative woodpock had let's go
to our districts let's say yes but you
should be supplied by the school
district
but it doesn't mean the school district
has to pay for it either there are
plenty of other ways for them to get it
my granddaughter as part of the Girl
Scout project went to various local
um
[Music]
drug stores and ask to set up a box that
asks people to buy these products and
put them in the box and then they could
be distributed from there and that was
something she did on her own and
collected quite a few feminine hygiene
projects products to be given to girls
in need at school
representative Mullen
thank you Mr chair
um
yes to many of the comments that have
been made one thing that we have not
addressed to this point is the fact that
the current statute has uh within it
guidance for school districts to seek
Partnerships from non-profit
organizations or uh it says
a school district May seek grants or
partner with a non-profit or
community-based organization to fulfill
their obligation
so
um there is nothing that precludes
school districts right now from seeking
out assistance from non-profit
organizations to cover the costs of this
without taking away the obligation that
the district has to make sure that the
product is provided
and the second thing is you know I'm
sure the governor's office heard all of
these arguments prior to his signing
this into law but he chose to sign it
into law anyhow and then there was a
great deal of positive feedback both uh
in the media and in the halls of the
legislature about what a wonderful thing
this was to recognize people that were
unable to provide their own product and
to partner with the schools so I would
encourage people to vote against this
bill and to not take away from a
vulnerable population something that is
essential to their well-being at school
thank you representative thank you Mr
chair I just want to address one issue
and that's the 28a issue this is a bogus
argument
the state underfunds many things here
let's take state standards for example
let's take State funding to schools
let's talk about cuts and budgets that
have to then be picked up by local disk
school districts I don't hear anyone
talking about a 28 a issue when those
come about but now when we deal with
this specific thing we say oh it's a 21
it's a 28a issue it's not an argument
there are greater issues that this state
does not fund that are 28a issues this
clearly does not fall into that category
thank you uh representative uh Tanner
thank you um
I don't know if uh I heard uh
representative lake is correctly or not
but toilet paper is not a an option uh
in schools uh I know of no school where
you have to bring your own toilet paper
um
so that that was one issue the other
thing is uh with the 28a since that
seems to be the focus is that the
lawsuit that representative Woodcock was
talking about was actually over the
state retirement responsibility when the
state who had put the retirement system
in into order uh suddenly decided it
wasn't going to pay for it and
downshifted that cost to the local
schools
uh a tremendous up increase in their
taxes local taxes
the that was taken to court as a 28-a
issue and that with that tremendous
Financial increase
was ruled by the court
as not a 28 a issue
and it was ruled as as not a 28-a issue
because it was part of the financial
responsibility of the school
and if toilet paper is a financial
and paper towels or some way to dry your
hands is a responsibility of the school
and to actually have bathroom facilities
in a school
then I think it's just uh it's not a 28a
um issue to include feminine hygiene
products as well and I totally agree
with
representative Allard that
schools that are really hurting
you know this is the school funding
issue schools that are really hurting
like his school like Newport my district
like Claremont you know four thousand
dollars is a big deal
and we really need to solve the school
funding issue so we're not fighting over
menstrual products as breaking the
budget thank you
thank you very much
representative
thank you very much Mr chair and I think
what representative Tanner and others
have said is uh is is really important
with with um particularly with respect
to to 28a uh representative Tanner is is
absolutely right you can't just sort of
pick and choose how you want to use it
um because the Supreme Court's already
told us how uh how to use it and and the
Supreme Court's on the record in the uh
in the New Hampshire retirement system
um case of of those downshifts to our
school districts that has to be
something more than merely a financial
obligation and I'd say the um the 35
downshift which represents something in
the amount of 40 50 million dollars a
year Statewide to school districts is
more than merely a financial obligation
but in fact the court said that that's
merely a financial obligation and it
said that that the state State action
must impose some and I'm reading from
the decision some substantive change to
the underlying function Duty or activity
performed or to be performed by local
government and clearly we're providing
sanitary type products
um at the um at the school districts in
a lot of different ways so so 28a just
clearly doesn't apply you can't pick and
choose but um but but I think the the
bigger point that that Linda was making
and others is that how we fund our
schools is is is is is also at um you
know is is also part of this and and
where we're starving our schools in
terms of in terms of
um financial support to a point where
where they need to
um they need to roll back things like
providing providing um hygiene products
I think is is is just a really sort of
pathetic state of State of Affairs but
finally Mr chair I just want to I I want
to sort of put out a practical
um
um issue uh also with respect to school
funding and uh and period poverty I
believe it was either on this bill or a
related bill that we heard that some
girls Miss as many as 40 days
out of 180 days of of school every year
and and for for anybody
um uh who who who you know thinks how
important it is to to go to school I
mean
um you know time is the currency of
public education so missing 40 days is
is a crime uh right there uh and we can
we can stop it but more importantly more
importantly
um those 40 days also represent it's
about 22 percent of the school year
that's also 22 percent of of one
full-time equivalent towards an adma and
every adma we know through the school
funding formula
is um um helps bring in the base of
3709 3700 dollars plus differentiated
Aid and all together you know on average
it may be about five thousand dollars so
22 percent of that is a thousand bucks
um so from a practical standpoint not
only can we help close the opportunity
gap for students that come from
low-income families that can't afford
these products we can provide them uh
what they need so that they can attend
the full 180 days they're certainly not
miss 40 of it associated with with their
time of the month
um but also the school district will
receive an additional thousand dollars
at least
from the um from the state adequacy
Grant so all in all I think this is this
is a plus for kids it's a plus for
school funding and um and it's a plus
for
um for all of us you know in the state
to have um to have our kids uh receive
um a quality educational outcome thank
you thank you very much now we're we've
been debating now for about 45 minutes
on this bill and what I'm going to allow
is that representative Woodcock do you
have your hand up and representative of
yours both of you have spoken before
um so go ahead and speak now but I'd
like to close this down uh shortly
thereafter
thank you representative I just want to
rectify a couple things first off I want
to thank the
good representative from Pittsfield
um I don't know how many others of you
around the board on zoom and or at the
room actually called or went to your
public schools and asked how the program
were working
so I appreciate the represent reality
took the initiative to do that and the
creativity of his town using the food
bank terrific
um and I understand the lack of funny
and small schools
and there was there was a thought maybe
we should go to our schools and uh
advocate for this in a regular basis I'm
happy to say that uh Conway and sau9 was
the head of the game before this bill
even came to the house two years ago
we've been doing that because we've had
the need and the awareness we've never
had any problems with things being
stolen tipped over or uh you know used
inappropriately
so I just want to clarify those things
and ask yourselves if you're a
legislator did you even bother calling
your school to see how many kids
actually taking advantage of this
actually are in school
um because of this uh and I was
reiterate the one thing I started with
30 days a year times six years there's
180 days of school these youngsters Miss
not not counting reteaching this is the
case of haves and have-nots it's a
perfect time to help the help to keep
students in school and help education
and I appreciate the second opportunity
representative I had to speak thank you
uh representative
that's regarding 28a if the schools
which they don't if the state I mean
which it doesn't require schools to
provide toilet paper and paper towels in
the bathrooms
this would not be a 28-day violation to
extend it but we don't require that
schools provided and that's all I'm
saying is schools can provide this just
like I'm not saying don't provide those
things where schools don't have to I'm
saying schools choose to and schools can
choose to provide this so that's number
one why it is a 28-day violation because
we don't mandate those things so it is a
new thing that we are mandating that we
did not mandate before but the other
point that I want to make is everybody's
talking about the money and how much it
costs and rep Ballard did and I also I
went and talked to my school district
because I was curious
um how it happened but rep Ballard was
talking about the things that his school
did the thing is this original Bill did
not provide any money
so it's not like oh well now we're going
to have if we take this away we won't
have this money or whatever we don't
have it now
the money was never provided to begin
with so all we're saying is
we're making the school spend money
we're not giving them any money for it
so let's let them make their own choice
and figure out how they're going to do
it like uh rep allards District did I
think that was a wonderful solution they
came to It's Perfectly allowable and
reasonable and they can continue to do
it whether or not they're mandated to
and if you think your school district
will decide not to do it Go convince
them to do it and if you think your
school district doesn't have money give
the uh give the
um example of re Ballard and his
district and what they did and
encouraged the school to continue
providing these things but we shouldn't
be mandating it that's all this is about
thank you
okay we have a motion on the table for
art to pass on uh hb4 58.
and I'm going to ask the clerk to uh
call enroll
I guess I'm HB 458.
representative cordelli yes
representative bones yes representative
Allard yes representative Lucas yes
yes
Bob said yes representative Andrews yes
that before
then lay on yes representative yes
representative
no
I've done it alone now no
because I'm sure I know representative
Cornell no
there's our scanner absolutely not
there's an Ellison I'm proud to vote no
on this
is that away
no is that in woodcock
no some should be ashamed
yes
seven nine
all right destinations
gonna do a press release on this
representative I should do a press
release on this let's let's uh stay on
topic here please and representative
Woodcock will do the Minority Report
thank you
I'd be happy to do that representative
Milo thank you and maybe do a photo up
with the governor
go for it
okay uh we now have uh in front of us HP
276 menstrual hygiene products uh
represent uh uh Hobson do you have a
motion
uh yeah I'd like to retain
s
okay and representative
Luis are you out there yes yeah I'll
snack on the Motions thank you very much
we have a motion on the table to retain
HP 276 mini fireworks and Hobson and
second by representative Andrus
today
okay thank you thank you very much uh
representative Andrus do you have
anything to add to that
um no I just I can concur with the Deb
on this
thank you let's open the discussion now
perhaps on woodcock
I'm looking I'm not going to start all
over again is beating a dead horse or a
phony around here somewhere but my
question is if if we have
um two 276 uh and 458 just past 11 to 9.
why why would a retain why would we
retain 276 which is a almost a
duplication Bill one's bad and one's
worst why why are we retaining a
duplication Bill why do we just itl
sir further discussion I mean that's a
quick that's a question representative
I'm trying to find out is chair why
would we take a duplication bill
I don't see anybody
like this
um they are different this one says the
state provides the money a number of
people
um
said if we thought this was valuable we
should have the state provide the money
and basically we want to see what the um
I want to see what the house in general
thinks about this whole thing if they
say yeah we should just get rid of it
cool if they say
no we shouldn't just get rid of it then
this allows us to still
instead of just
um
not being able to bring this up at all
we have this retained to say okay you
don't want to get rid of it do you want
to do this instead that's that's why
makes no sense
[Music]
thank you Mr chair for uh addressing me
so quickly
um a question about how a district would
go about seeking reimbursement
I mean is there a process in place or uh
what would a new process have to be
created
yeah they probably would need to be all
the more reason to retain it so we could
figure that out if we need to okay
thank you
representative
um I'm just wondering does this re apply
to toilet paper now that we know that
schools aren't required to supply toilet
paper
the bill doesn't speak the toilet paper
at all so uh
that's not what we're discussion
through the discussion
okay if we have a motion on the table
for retaining this bill
call the roll
s okay
this is uh
about to pass
a retention uh
uh wholesale 276.
representative cordelli yes
representative yes
representative Aller yes representative
yes representative Moffett yes
representative
representative Andrus yes representative
Ford
yes representative Leon yes
representative yes Representative no
we'll know no
representative Shaw no for now so
Representative no
Senator Ellison no
Mullen no
light no
he's in a wood car no
representative Ladd yes
all right nine seven nine
first stops you'll be ready to be
um
[Music]
thank you
okay
um
keep going in the order we did jump over
before let's take care of that that was
the first one representative was not
here when we were going to do that so
that he is back
this is through the commission school
funding
wait 464.
an easy one is good morning
thank you representative Ladd are you
recognizing me for something
I was just a saying that we we were
going to do this bill prior to you
getting back after the elections I was
letting Ozzy out yeah
oh that's important
let me pull up did everybody receive the
amendment yes uh the amendment is zero
eight four one h
M and what I will do is I'll hand the
gavel over to uh represent cordelli and
I'll make a motion
remote
okay relevant relative to 464. I offer
the
um I recommend podcasts but with this
amendment uh the amendment is uh zero
eight four one it's made by myself
um the mission or the amendment simply
says it's relative to the study schools
study funding commission domestic shell
repeal upon the passage of of this uh
of this bill is there a second or excuse
me is there a second
no second
after those seconds
but the commission study report was
issued prior uh honor before January 10
um the initial report was submitted
earlier than that
um and then the current legislation
indicated that the subsequent uh
recommendation would be issue report
that has been done by January 10th so at
this point in time the final report has
been issued and we've seen in the past
were some of the commissions
and just keep going on not not forever
um
Transmissions uh done its job and it's
made its recommendations so the this
this amendment simply states that the
commission will cease pending passage of
this bill
thank you
yeah uh thanks very much Mr chair I
think representative Ladd
um I got that pretty uh pretty much
um you know we were both members of the
commission uh during its uh during its
active period uh in researching and
developing uh the reports the report's
been filed
um there's certainly a lot more work to
do when it comes to school funding but I
think it moves beyond the commission uh
at this point uh or has moved beyond the
commission at this point into the
legislative branch executive branch
um and um and obviously Advocates too so
um so uh uh commission members I'm sure
will continue to be
um vocal in in uh in in their um you
know positions one way or the other when
it comes to the findings or particularly
recommendations but uh but but I think
as far as procedural uh course goes this
makes a lot of sense thanks
offensive further discussion
I think not seeing
kind of first things
um
okay this is five to pass on Amendment
[Music]
zero eight four one
it's a house bill 464 Metro yes
representative yes
representative bone yes
representative Valor yes representative
yes representative yes representative
yes representative Andrus yes
representative board yes
representative Leon yes
yes
I'm sure I guess representative Cornell
yes Tanner
yes president Allison yes yes
sir
whoever you are
I know I'm gonna swallow this
oh representative way
yes
representative Woodcock no
representative lab yes
so that's 19-1 on the amendment
work
[Music]
places on consent
no I gotta make a motion here to approve
the bill as amended through this bill
when this amendment
um which is 0841h
and then and that's there a second or
excuse me
thank you
any further discussion is it 4818 or
8418 thank you okay you reverse your
numbers
Wisconsin
I could pass as amended
on whatever Bill we're talking about
um
[Music]
representative cordelli yeah
representative ball yes representative
Allard yes representative yes
representative Moffett yes
representative yes representative Andrus
yes
representative Leon yes representative
Saudi yes it's in a Miler yes
representative yes
and sure yes representative Cornell yes
representative yes Zach Ellison
yes and Senator Mullen yes
no
no yes
18-2
yeah yes
okay
Minority Report
no no
uh Rick who's going to do the majority
report on this or the I will
yes yes I I make emotions
thank you
yeah thank you
um there are two bills left for today uh
HP
school lunch program
okay and I'd like to uh call rips at the
latest for emotions
yes I would like to move to itl
um
HB 202. Jackson Hobson second
um we have a motion for itl on 202 made
by Professor Lakers and second by drips
to Hobson representative would you like
to speak to him motion yeah this bill
sounded wonderful I thought it was a
great idea I was planning on voting for
it and then when we had public testimony
which is the reason we have public
testimony is that I then learned that it
was unnecessary because it was already
being done that there are we're already
rsas covering this and that it says you
know this is
since it's already being done and
whatever then we don't actually need
this bill
um I don't remember what the rsas were
they break them down unfortunately for
what covers this but
having been told that there's no reason
for us to do this one thank you
with the second I'd like to speak to the
Village
um no thank you uh just that we heard a
testimony that um
thank you representative Mullen
thank you Mr chair I'll speak to this uh
briefly uh yes we did hear testimony
from uh Sherry white at the Department
of Education it's RSA 189 11a and
while it is true that we do have a meals
program
that is in place for elementary schools
it does not extend to uh middle and high
school
so uh the initial part of the bill which
basically uh is that we will provide
free meals to uh
any student at school who is hungry who
lacks the capacity to either clear their
deficit balance or
pay for a meal with cash
that is the spirit of the law but that
law does not apply to older children and
uh I would venture a guess that our high
school age kids are equally as hungry if
not more
than their Elementary
counterparts so I would ask you to
reconsider that aspect of us already
doing things thank you thank you very
much further discussion
thank you Mr chair
um last session we passed this when it
was House Bill 1127 it went to the house
and we passed by a vote Voice vote
um and it's one of the bills that died
along with covid when we had too many
bills
um and it had other things it does have
other things in it like not um
stigmatizing the child by handing him a
note in front of everybody to bring home
or you know offering them a lunch that's
different than everybody else's like I
can remember way back when when I worked
at Parkside
um they would be given a yogurt when
everybody else was give being given a
full meal so I think this bill is
necessary
thank you representative
yes thank you Mr chair just a question
who pays for this this is the 28a
it is we shouldn't vote for it
how long is I'm just asking because it's
something we're currently doing and um
trying to provide to all people in need
to be like like other bills you may have
had today
I believe that um Sherry white indicated
that there was that was not happening
currently she said that all students
were getting the same lunches so
um and I don't see any Precision in the
bill
that um
other than it it uh that's the
stigmatization
um
that's the only thing that I think it
doesn't say anything about a particular
age group in the middle
um unless I'm mistaken they've
representative
uh and the school board makes the
decision
um so so I I'm happy to listen to the
um
the debate on this but I just don't see
it
with the way that kind of Technology
can you give me the I apparently wrote
down the wrong RSA can you give me the
RSA again rep Nolan yes it's I'm looking
at 189 uh 11a
[Music]
okay but it's going to take me a while
to dig out uh the the comment that I was
referencing
and that's also in uh
education rules 306
about 11 food nutrition services
it deals with requiring that each School
makes a meal available during school
hours to every student under the
jurisdiction you can't afford to it that
our saving was just supported Roman 1
and through Roman 2.
it's also my understanding that during
this period of covet this has created a
financial issue with schools where all
students have been receiving meals at no
cost
and that's impacting uh programs which
we
generate
um funding for for the students that do
qualify based upon poverty and there's
going to have to be some special
assistance done for schools that are in
this category so the funding will not
stop
yeah so it represent them all in your
hand is still up
it is it's newly up uh in the handout
that Ms White sent to us
the section that is titled
considerations for creating meal
charging policies standard practice
number three
according to FNS instructions revision
two at the very least the alternate meal
must always be offered to pre-primary
and any child who has not entered the
first grade and to Young Primary
Elementary students or for any
handicapped or disabled students the
meal offered uh must conform to special
dietary needs if applicable it does not
mention middle school or high school
students in that section it applies to
pre-primary and elementary schools
that's the alternate meal
further discussion
not see any I'm still not seeing
um in reading all of 189 11a I'm not
still not seeing anything
um
I'm still not finding anything that says
that it doesn't apply to all students in
all schools
two of the Department of Education
technical advisory that Sherry white
sent to us page two Under The Heading
considerations for creating meal
charging policies number three
so I'm looking at the document that she
sent us not part of the original Law is
that what you're saying uh I don't it's
the interpretation that the department
of Ed sent to us
okay do you have representative
uh want to run two in front of me right
now I do not
because in that in the education rules
it says exactly it says uh shall make a
meal available during school hours to
every student under its jurisdiction so
the school has to provide to every
student under his jurisdiction no I'm
just asking does that applied just after
elementary schools with middle schools
junior high schools high schools
okay so noted yeah so I you know maybe
we need to we need to you know figure it
out here clarification Mr Mr chair can I
make a point of order for a minute
um the other years that I've served on
the education committee
we've received this booklet okay booklet
on uh New Hampshire education laws
annotated
uh since representative Mullins been on
the education committee we haven't been
provided with that book and it makes a
huge difference when you're talking
about the issues that we're talking
about right now to be able to have that
book available and look it up
um I'm looking it up from the 2018-19
Edition I don't think there's been a
whole lot of change since then but I
think that should be made available to
our committee members thank you that's
in response to that as we call it the
beginning when we started this we were
told by Department of Education they're
going to think a thumb drive with the
statutes on that for each person we have
not received it as of this point
um and of course you can access all
these statutes if you go to the general
core website and look underneath uh
state laws browse their search yep and
it's it's not annotated though and the
annotations make a a big deal of
difference on some of the bills and it's
not in paper some of us old folks
uh need paper stuff and you can see that
uh representative Mullen has spent money
to run things off
um and it's getting a little pricey at
this point
um I actually have I do have a question
so um I appreciate that book however
that RSA that we've been quoted uh 189
11a has been updated in 2019 and the
advisory that we were sent was actually
issued November 15 2016. so the statute
that's referenced is actually more
current than the advisory under um
under uh
Jefferson shop
from what she read from that uh I know
exactly what uh representative Mullen
had in her hands because it was sent to
all of us from uh Sherry I didn't print
it out but that clearly does not State
um
High School
or middle school
and I think that that is the key to this
is that it's not stated in law
Elementary yeah there's no problem in
the elementary school
but Junior I I subbed in the middle
school
for four years and I was handing out a
dollar bills like crazy because I saw
kids sitting there with nothing in front
of them guys you know aren't you hungry
I don't have a meal card or I lost my
meal card or you know that and I know
what it's like I have four in that age
level right now and they're lucky they
know where their pants are in the
morning so it's it's very important that
those kids get taken care of too and the
high school kids poverty doesn't stop
when you get into Middle School
and I think that uh this would be a good
bill to pass
I don't agree with the IPO I think it's
important anything that we can get in
the hands of kids today is a good thing
and I think that that because that's not
clearly understood by the department of
Ed I think that means that we need to
have something from us in writing thank
you representative
um I would like to point out again that
that is the same thing that I pulled up
in my email that we're referring to that
was from November 15th of 2016. the
statutes have been updated since then
does it say high school and medical it
says all students it says each School
each school is what's currently in the
law
doesn't say anything about grades at all
so that 2016 one is out of date
this got updated in 2019 and it says
each School
I
I Mr chair with your Indulgence I'm just
going to respond to that because I I
feel like this is the dialogue that I'm
in
um I don't feel confident representative
Leon and representative Lucas I hear
what you're saying that it says that the
statute was updated in uh 2019 I just
don't know what part of the statute was
updated in 2019 I I don't I I mean I
don't know that you know that either
um I understand the data is on the RSA
but
um this is a technical advisory document
that came from the Department of
Education so this is what they're using
to go by in making their decisions uh
and I also you know I'm not looking to
make this into a huge issue I just uh
feel that
rather than it yelling this we ought to
be looking at whether or not there's
Merit in retaining it or passing it
can I can I read Section 8 of the
current law
there's a school lunch meal payment
policy which is implemented by a school
board either before after the effective
date of this section challenge sure that
all students have access to a healthy
school lunch that the school district
will make every reasonable effort to
inform parents of the policy and that no
student will be subject to different
treatment from the standard school lunch
meal or school's cafeteria procedures
the Department of Education or the State
Board of Education upon request of the
local school board May provide
communication assistance to school
districts and parents of school children
regarding the school lunch meal payment
policy basically that says what this was
trying to do it's already been done
it's in it's that's current law
okay so that could I respond to that Mr
chair Mr Man
um yes representative fleckis if that
change has been made and it's not
reflected in the technical advisory from
the doe then obviously we need to look
at where the disconnect is in that in
addition to that there's a section of
the bill that deals with
um communication between the Food
Services Program and the family
um that indicates that only the family
the parents or Guardians will be in
conversation about insufficient funds or
it's uh
section c Roman Roman nine line eight
Roman nine section c
right
but this this I mean in that it says the
school district will make every
reasonable effort to inform parents
right it doesn't say informed Church
students it says Mr chairman
must help sorry
yeah I'm sorry I'm just trying to say
what the current law is because I have
it right in front of them
yeah do we have anybody from the
Department of Ed
listening in today I mean it's common
practice to ask for advice
uh at least on other committees that
I've been on
um from the administrative side of
things if they have anything to say that
perhaps could clarify this situation
here since there seems to be a
discrepancy potentially between statute
and uh the Department's administrative
guidelines yes we do have attorney
Fenton on here on board we can have her
and perhaps if you need me we can get
somebody that's working with the
nutrition program there at doe to get
involved in this too so uh I I feel
uncomfortable passing anything where
this is disconnect or an advisory says
one thing the statutory is something
that what what are we dealing with here
so that needs some resolution is Diane
there
thank you okay go ahead
good afternoon
uh so I've been looking at 189 11a and
the technical advisory
um I was texting with Sherry White
she does believe that the law is
applicable to all the grades but because
the doe issue advisory
that states something contrary to that
I'm hesitant to stand behind that um
we need to correct that ta if that's the
guidance we're actually putting out so I
would request some time to have sherry
white actually address that inquiry but
from my reading of 18911 a
[Music]
and the amendment that was passed I
think it is applicable to all ages but I
understand where rep Mullins
question comes from and I think it's
worth taking the time to make sure that
the doe can properly address that and
I'm just not the person to really be
able to address that
um I would prefer to Sherry white so let
me just see if she can hop on you give
me just two seconds
um I'm gonna ask Sherry white to hop on
the
discussion
I think we're where I'm going to go with
this right now is that uh we need to
have specific clarification from the
Department I don't want to guesswork
over there I want things to be solid I
want to see it in print so I'm not going
to go any further with this bill today
um we're gonna pull it stop right there
recess this bill until the Tuesday of
next week
when we will have more information back
I know when Diana gets back I'll let her
know that but uh I think there's uh
there's just too much acrimony on it not
acrimony but too much there's just a
disconnect I don't know what we've been
giving them that advisory and what we
see in statute and this legislature
wants to know exactly what's going on
um so that's my recommendation
not well I like that Diana said she's
coming back but we'll explain it to her
as well uh when when she gets back at
her desk
no if she's coming back I don't want you
to say You're Gone Diana and she comes
back okay
um I don't want anybody there having to
reach out and make adjustment based upon
who knows what
um
do I need to recall the motion so that
we can recess
I mean next week
but depending upon what we find out but
um
I don't want to know
chairman I believe Sherry white will be
joining you shortly Diane Were You There
When I just spoke to the committee
I would
do is that I'm not going to take any
further on this bill today and most
likely we will discuss this then uh one
one week from today on the following
Tuesday when we can get more specific
information from you and from the
Department regarding the nutrition
program uh as to where we are with that
advisory where we are with statue and
basically there are three items in that
bill right now which I'm concerned with
minerals 9 a b and c
um
different or
dealing with uh
and then the prohibiting of a child who
cannot pay for a meal uh from doing any
work I don't that that's obviously to me
not a practice that schools should be
doing for all
um and and I'd like to know if there's
anything that's mentioned to that either
in rule or it's not just or in a federal
advisory
and then three uh that Communications
that are going home yes they can be
given to a student but they're not going
to be communicated to the student to
then verbalize them and send them that
way
um through the student that's uh not
really a great idea
uh so
um there's some great points there in
that bill
I've just always been as a school
principal under the assumption that
those things were in place and we were
doing those things
but I don't know if that's the case
throughout New Hampshire
okay
you know we have another a bill dealing
with uh school lunch and I prefer not to
take that up until we get some
clarification on this bill so what I'm
going to do because I did communicate
these five bills to representative at
the lunch break we did three of them we
have two to two here plus a few others
still so uh I'm not going to go forward
with any other bills today
uh we have a couple members here that
have to be out of here to pick up kids
out of school by 2 30
um we're closing into that hour so uh
are there any more Communications or
suggestions from from the committee as a
whole
everybody
all right good okay thank you very much
for help so I wish everybody a good
afternoon and we'll see some of you
tomorrow at 10 o'clock
on Thursday
thank you thank you
I'll see you tomorrow
our wealthy be great